Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du deine Experten-Frisur angelegt?
Selbstverständlich.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik, die 90. Ausgabe, jetzt hier im Januar 2014. Linus, es geht voran.
Ich hoffe, ja.
Ja, es geht voran. Und die Debatten scheinen sich jetzt auch zu entfesseln. Nachdem der Kongress abgefeiert ist, kommt man jetzt langsam offiziell ins Grübeln, hab ich so den Eindruck.
Ja, Sascha Lobo hat einen Debattenbeitrag in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung verfasst und wurde daraufhin die Relevanz erhoben und zu uns als Gast eingeladen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sascha.
Wir mussten die Debatte dann auch mal hier in die Sendung tragen. Nicht, dass wir hier nicht schon eine Menge darüber debattiert hätten. Worüber denn eigentlich? Sascha hat gesagt, das Internet ist kaputt. Zumindest so wird es dir unterstellt.
Das ist schön, dass du diesen Nachsatz noch dahinter schiebst. Ich möchte vielleicht einfach am Anfang den Originalsatz zitieren. Das Internet ist kaputt. Die Idee der digitalen Vernetzung ist es nicht. Meiner Meinung nach sind beide Satzteile sehr wichtig. Zitiert wird natürlich dann nur der erste. Da möchte ich mich gar nicht grundsätzlich darüber beschweren. Das ist eben bei Debattenartikeln so, dass man das häufig verkürzen und möchte. Aber grundsätzlich ist das natürlich eine Metapher dafür, dass diese Spähsituation, dieser Spähskandal, wo einem ja auch so ein bisschen die Worte fehlen, weil es ist nicht richtig ein Skandal. Es ist schon gar keine Affäre, die irgendwie dann bald wieder aufhört. Aber dieses Späh-Debakel, das hat etwas mit uns gemacht. Und ich glaube, es hat mit allen etwas gemacht. Ob das jetzt eine Kränkung ist, wie ich versucht habe zu diagnostizieren, darüber kann man sich streiten. Das wird ja auch schon darüber gestritten. Es hat aber vor allem gezeigt, dass das Internet nicht nur bloß missbraucht wird zur Überwachung der Welt, sondern dass seit vielen Jahren an entscheidenden Stellen von der Infrastruktur, der technischen Infrastruktur über Hardware, Software bis zu Gesetzen eine ganze Menge von Regelungen getroffen wurden oder Veränderungen gemacht wurden, um das Internet möglichst spähfreundlicher hinzubekommen. Und ich glaube, dass dieser, dieses Moment nicht unterschätzt werden darf. Dass wirklich Behörden von Anfang an daran gearbeitet haben, das Internet so aufzubauen, wie es heute ist. Und das bedeutet auch, weniger sicher, leichter zu kontrollieren. Überwachung und Kontrolle gehen Hand in Hand. Wenn ich mir anschaue, dass seit vielen Jahren Verschlüsselungen systematisch schwächer gemacht werden. Wenn ich mir anschaue, dass das Internet mit dem Versprechen, so dezentral wie möglich zu sein, das war ursprünglich mal der Gedanke, dass das Internet technologisch wahnsinnig zentralisiert ist. Dann sehe ich, ja, man kann davon sprechen, auch wenn das natürlich nur eine Metapher ist, man kann davon sprechen, dass das Internet kaputt ist.
Du bist aber richtig so persönlich betroffen, ne?
Ich bin gekränkt, das habe ich auch geschrieben. Ich bin davon gekränkt, unter anderem deshalb, weil ich ja eine bestimmte Position in der Öffentlichkeit habe. Wenn ich in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung einen Artikel schreibe, dann schreibe ich den, auch wenn viele Leute, die ja selbst der Nabel der Welt sind, das vielleicht nicht sofort begreifen, aber dann schreibe ich den jetzt nicht in erster Linie für die Netzgemeinde oder so. Dann schreibe ich den für die Leute dort draußen. Für eine Öffentlichkeit, die eben schon mal von Twitter gehört hat, aber jetzt nicht jeden Tag auf Blogs unterwegs ist. Meine Funktion bei denen ist, zum einen kennen die meisten nicht unbedingt meinen Namen, die erkennen mich aber aufgrund der Frisur schon auch wieder. Und da war ich halt über Jahre der, der in der Talkshow gesagt hat oder der in Artikeln, die sie so sphärisch wahrgenommen hat, gesagt hat, ey kommt alle ins Netz, das ist ganz super. Und ich war der, der gesagt hat, die digitale Welt ist was Schönes, wir können alle zusammen, ihr macht euch unnötige Sorgen, kommt alle her. Dass das vielleicht nicht immer die Position ist, die ich in meinen Artikeln vertreten habe oder in vielen Büchern vertreten habe, dass ich da sehr abwägend formuliert habe, das ist eine zweite Sache. Mein letztes Buch hieß Internet Segen oder Fluch vor dem Späßkandal 2012. Also mir ist schon bewusst, dass es eine positive und eine negative Seite gibt. Aber in der Öffentlichkeit habe ich eher die sehr freundliche und sehr positive Seite ausgespielt und ich habe natürlich auch davon profitiert, das darf man nicht verschweigen.
Du standest aber natürlich auch anderen einwenden und anderen Befürchtungen gegenüber. Also ich würde jetzt zu deinem Schutz sogar sagen, den einwenden und Befürchtungen, den du damals gegenüber standest, hast du ja auch adäquat.
Ach Schutz, ich fühle mich nicht so, als würde ich Schutz brauchen. Aber vielen Dank trotzdem natürlich. Zu deinem Trost. Auch Trost, naja. Aber das hat Tim schon ganz richtig erkannt. Ich fühle mich persönlich betroffen. Aber ich glaube, dass die meisten Leute sich persönlich betroffen fühlen sollten, wenn sie begreifen würden, wie tiefgreifend da eine Gesellschaft kontrolliert wird. Das ist ja nicht nur Überwachung. Das ist ja der große Trugschluss. Es geht ja nicht nur um Überwachung. Überwachung ist da ein Mittel zum Zweck der Kontrolle. Diese Kontrolle, die sehr viel umfassender ist, als die meisten Leute sich das eingestehen wollen, die kann man durchaus als eigenen Machtverlust, als Verlust der Gestaltungsmöglichkeit, der Gestaltungshoheit, des eigenen Lebens begreifen. Gerade wenn das digital ist. Und das gerade aus den Bereichen der Krypto-Gemeinde, der Leute, die schon immer alles verschlüsseln wollen. Ich würde jetzt mal das CCC-Umfeld dazu rechnen, dass da, und das habe ich auch ganz deutlich versucht, in dem Artikel zu formulieren, dass da sich bestimmte vermeintliche Verschwörungstheorien in Realität noch als Untertreibung herausgestellt haben. Das tut etwas mit den Leuten. Das macht etwas mit der Gesellschaft. Das ist eine Kränkung. Das kann man mir einfach nicht erzählen. Wenn Pofalla im Sommer einen Hubschrauber im Tiefflug über das amerikanische Konsulat jagt, eine hilflose, peinliche Geste, natürlich steht da eine Kränkung dahinter. Wenn Angela Merkel am Telefon ruft Obama an und sagt, NSA is like the Stasi, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob die Deutsch oder Englisch reden, wie tief kann man denn gekränkt sein, damit eine ostdeutsche Kanzlerin einer amerikanischen Präsidentin mit einem Stasi-Vergleich kommt? Natürlich ist das eine Kränkung. Natürlich geht es darum, dass man sich getäuscht hat über das Netz. Und natürlich haben diese Täuschungen fast alle mitgemacht. Wir kennen alle die Ausnahmen, die gesagt haben, hey, theoretisch ist es möglich, es abzuhören, also wird das auch gemacht. Aber sogar bei den Leuten sind viele überrascht, wie radikal da vorgegangen worden ist, wie umfassend und hemmungslos das passiert. Und vor allem Vermutung, Ahnung, Möglichkeit, Gerücht ist das eine. Eine faktische Bestätigung davon, dass man Dokumente hat, die das beweisen, weil ihnen wurde nicht widersprochen. 250 der besten Investigativjournalisten haben sich darauf gestürzt, weltweit. Man kann das als Fakten begreifen. Und das ist ein Unterschied in dem Moment, wo man faktisch weiß, es wird alles überwacht. Oder wo man glaubt, na ja, es ist eine hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit und ich bin ziemlich überzeugt davon, dass alles überwacht wird. Und diesen Unterschied, der ist für mich substanziell. Und ja, er hat mich gekränkt. Und ja, das hat mich mitgenommen. Und ja, das hat meinen früheren Internet-Optimismus kaputt gemacht, zerstört. Zumindest irgendwie hinfällig werden lassen und ich brauche einen neuen. Und meine Unterstellung wäre, dass die gesamte Gesellschaft einen neuen braucht. Weil nur mit so einer Vision, so einem digitalen Narrativ hat man überhaupt eine Chance, alle Leute mitzunehmen und zu sagen, ok, es wird überwacht, aber wir müssen trotzdem daran arbeiten, wie eine digitale Gesellschaft zusammenkommt. Und zwar alle zusammen.
Du hast jetzt gerade den Begriff der Kränkung einmal auf die Bürger und Bevölkerung angewandt, aber auch auf die Bundesregierung. Würdest du sagen, dass da die Kränkung die gleiche ist?
Nein, wenn man auf die Fußgängerzonen Leute zugeht, dann sieht man ja, die sind eher nicht gekränkt. Ich gehe jetzt nicht irgendwie durch die Straßen und sehe geknickte, traurige Menschen wegen der Überwachung. Im Gegenteil. Ich habe aber ja auch diesen Vergleich benutzt, um überhaupt erst mal zu zeigen, wie sich eine Kränkung äußert. Und dass sie natürlich manche Leute früher oder intensiver wahrnehmen, ist auch der Fall. Ich glaube, das wird sich nach und nach durch die Gesellschaft durchziehen. Das ist jetzt vor ein paar Tagen, ich glaube vorgestern, gerade der erste wirklich nachweislich beschriebene, dokumentierte Fall von aggressiver Wirtschaftsspionage jenseits aller Sicherheitsblablas, bekannt geworden, Ferro Stahl, eine Firma, ich glaube aus dem Ruhrgebiet, wo ein Angebot abgegeben worden ist. Und so war es jedenfalls in der westen.de zu lesen. Ein Angebot abgegeben worden ist von Ferro Stahl. Ich glaube, es war in Nigeria, aber ich bin mir nicht mehr hundertprozentig sicher. Und wo dieses Angebot ganz offensichtlich abgefangen wurde von einer Geheimdienstmaschinerie, weitergeleitet wurde an den amerikanischen Konkurrenten, der das anschließend natürlich genau deshalb unterbieten konnte. Das ist also aggressive Wirtschaftsspionage völlig ohne Sicherheitsbezug. Das ist inzwischen bekannt geworden. Und natürlich ist es eine Kränkung für die Wirtschaft, weil es ihre Versprechen unterhöhlt. Du machst das beste Angebot, du hast die beste Leistung, also kriegst du den Auftrag. Das ist ja gerade die Essenz von Marktwirtschaft. Insofern, ich glaube, und das habe ich in dem Artikel auch formuliert, da habe ich nichts zurückzunehmen oder fein zu respektieren, ich spüre diese Kränkung, ich spüre sie früher als andere. Sie wird nicht von allen gespürt werden. Aber die Essenz davon, wir haben uns getäuscht. Es ist anders, die Welt funktioniert anders, als wir gehofft haben. Vielleicht auch gehofft haben. Ich habe ja diesen Moment versucht, mit reinzubringen. Das wird, glaube ich, vielen Leuten so gehen. Der Politik ist es schon so gegangen, das ist ganz offensichtlich. Mir ist es natürlich auch so gegangen. Deswegen habe ich einen Artikel geschrieben. Bei der Wirtschaft gibt es ein Umdenken. Ich glaube, dass es bei vielen Leuten in der Bevölkerung auch irgendwann ankommt.
Also, noch mal zu der Frage, die ich gerade gestellt habe. Ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass ausgerechnet Pofalla und Merkel jetzt ein großes Freiheitsversprechen des Internets in ihrem Herzen gespült haben und sich jetzt gekränkt fühlen. Also, ich glaube, da ist die Kränkung eher eine andere. Sie denken, wir haben hier unsere kleinen BNDs oder was und versuchen, der Sache Herr zu werden. Und in Wirklichkeit hängt da eine andere Regierung so stark drin, dass sie die komplette Souveränität unserer Bundesrepublik untergräbt und damit natürlich auch meine eigene Macht. Das wäre jetzt so meine persönliche Frage.
Du hast die Frage so ein bisschen sehr suggestiv gestellt. Natürlich ist jetzt Frau Merkel nicht besonders bekannt dafür, dass sie einem großen Freiheitsversprechen des Internets jeden Tag ein Gebet widmet. Das ist vollkommen klar. Als ich versucht habe, diese Kränkung zu beschreiben in dem Artikel, den du ja auswendig gelernt hast, habe ich extra versucht, darauf hinzuweisen, dass hier das Internet ein Mittel zum Zweck ist. Natürlich fühlt sich Frau Merkel nicht durch irgendwelche Internetüberwachung angegriffen. Aber wenn das Netz, wenn die digitale Vernetzung, wenn die Kommunikationsnetze insgesamt so abgehorcht werden, dann empfindet sie das als Kränkung, als Vertrauensbruch. Darauf kommt es an, dass natürlich diese Kränkung bei jedem sich anders äußert, ist auch klar. Aber ich glaube, dass es insbesondere bei der Politik da weniger um das Internet geht und viel mehr tatsächlich um das, was du angesprochen hast, um das Gefühl der Souveränität, um das Gefühl des Vertrauens, um auch das Gefühl der Machtlosigkeit. Ich meine, Volker Kauder, und ich bin wirklich kein Freund von Frau Kauder, oder in ungefähr keiner Hinsicht. Aber der hat vor einigen Tagen zugegeben, ja, wir haben nicht so richtig ein Druckmittel, wir sind in einem klassischen Dilemma. Ich paraphrasiere das, das hat er fast wörtlich gesagt. Wenn man als Politiker merkt, dass die Macht ein sehr deutliches, eigenes Ende hat, und die besteht nicht aus Gesetzen oder demokratischen Wahlen, sondern aus der Willkür eines anderen Staates, das ist sehr schwierig zu ertragen. Und dass er das offen zugegeben hat, zeigt, wie weit das da gekommen ist.
Was machen wir jetzt?
Wenn ich das wüsste. Mein Artikel, mein Debattenartikel ist von vielen Leuten als depressiv oder weinerlich wahrgenommen worden. Ich wollte nicht hinterm Berg halten, dass mich das mitgenommen hat, ernsthaft mitgenommen hat. Dieses Recht habe ich mir herausgenommen. Ich benutze sehr selten das Wort ich in Artikeln. Da habe ich es deswegen absichtlich getan, weil es hat eine emotionale Komponente. Aber um auf deine Frage zu antworten, was machen wir jetzt, deswegen hat trotz dieser Traurigkeit in dem Artikel oder dieser Belastung, die ich dargestellt habe, der Artikel geendet in einer Art Aufruf, in einer Art Wunsch, dass man gemeinsam ein positives Narrativ entwickelt. Dass man gemeinsam einen Internetoptimismus entwickelt. Das kann ich nicht, es kam häufig die Frage, warum ich den dann nicht in den Artikel geschrieben habe. Das ist natürlich totaler Quatsch. Der Artikel war ja, du hast ja die Seite voll gehabt. Ja, das ist ein sehr kluges Argument, danke. Nein, faktisch hängt es eher damit zusammen, dass ich völlig außerstandig bin, alleine ein solches Narrativ zu entwickeln. Das ist eine Diskussion, die man braucht von vielen Beteiligten. Und ich glaube eben von viel mehr Beteiligten als das bisherige Internetnarrativ. Das so ein bisschen mit Freiheitsversprechen. Und irgendwie hat man dann ja auch in Nordafrika, Facebook-Revolution, alles so ein bisschen vermischt. Und ich kann jetzt jeden Song hören in drei Sekunden, wenn ich möchte. Und da ist irgendwie schon persönliche Freiheit. Und am anderen Ende der Welt. Irgendwie hat es so eine eigene Gestaltungssoheit und Möglichkeitenräume neu eröffnet. Und das ist alles gut und schön. Aber es hat eben einen sehr großen Schlag bekommen durch diese Überwachung. Und ich glaube, dass deswegen eine neue Erzählung, die man gemeinsam entwickelt, dass sie so eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion werden muss. Dass man auch die Leute mitnimmt, die sich bisher vom Internet ausgeschlossen gefühlt haben. Worauf es mir ankommt, und das ist das eigentliche Ziel hinter diesem Aufruf zur Entwicklung eines neuen digitalen Optimismus. Worauf es mir ankommt, ich glaube, wir haben keine Chance als die digitale Gesellschaft, die kommt, zu gestalten, mitzugestalten, vor den bösartigen Gestaltern zu versuchen, das Schlimmste zu bewahren. Und ich glaube, dass die Gesellschaft da zurückfinden muss zu einer eigenen Deutungshoheit, in was für einer Gesellschaft möchte man leben. Deswegen halte ich es für sehr wichtig, dass man zum einen erstmal sagt, was ich getan habe, das, was ich bisher verfolgt habe, war so nicht richtig. Wenn ich mich geirrt habe, möchte ich auch sagen, dass ich mich geirrt habe. Ich möchte nicht so tun, als das Fächeln wir mal weg. Ich glaube, wir brauchen eine Art Neuanfang und da wollte ich mit Wucht versuchen, den zu ermöglichen.
Ich denke, es ist dir auch sehr gut gelungen. Jetzt wird mich ein Punkt noch interessieren. Der Artikel ist wirklich sehr persönlich. Als wir auf dich gewartet haben, ist es mir aufgefallen, dass du in der Spon-Kolumne, die du schreibst, glaube ich seit Beginn dieses Debakels, keine einzige Kolumne geschrieben hast, die sich nicht damit beschäftigt hat. Du hast dich wirklich, das beschäftigt dich wirklich und ist auch offensichtlich. Du hast ja auch sehr interessante Gedanken zu formuliert und hast auch deine Wut teilweise sehr zum Ausdruck gebracht. Jetzt würde mich noch eine Sache, wenn wir schon auf der persönlichen Ebene sind, interessieren. Wie reflektierst du denn jetzt deine Rolle, dein Leben als Internet-Erklärer irgendwie in den letzten sechs bis acht Jahren ungefähr, in denen du da jetzt eine besondere Präsenz hattest? Würdest du jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, da hätte ich was anders machen müssen?
Das kann man natürlich danach immer sagen. Ich hätte einfach den Unfug weglassen sollen und nur die klugen Sachen machen sollen. Aber das geht, glaube ich, jedem so. Ich höre mich jetzt über die eigenen Kopfhörer so an, als würde ich dauernd lispeln. Ich weiß gar nicht...
Es geht noch.
Nein, es geht noch. Tatsächlich glaube ich, dass ich natürlich, wenn ich gewusst hätte, zum Beispiel um diese Ausspähung bestimmte Sachen anders formuliert hätte. Ich habe ganz oft so was geschrieben wie mit Facebook, das ist ganz spannend, und schaut euch das mal an, geht mal da rein, es ist nicht schlimm, man kann... Ihr könnt ja dann so ein bisschen auch versuchen, zu kontrollieren, welche Daten da reinkommen und so. Unter heutiger Sicht hätte man jeder von diesen Diskussionen, das habe ich in den Debattenartikel auch geschrieben, einfach anfügen müssen. Und übrigens öffnest du damit eine schöne Schleuse bis auf die NSA-Server, um es mal platt zu sagen. Ich möchte nicht so tun, als sei das nicht so. Ich kann aber auch nicht sagen, meine Rolle damals war dumm und stumpfsinnig. Ich habe ja schon gesagt, ich war bis zu einem bestimmten Teil naiv. Was sehr lustig ist, weil ich eröffne einen Artikel damit, zu sagen, ich war naiv. Und 50% der Reaktionen, auch in Erwachsenenzeitungen, sagen, du warst ja naiv. Das schreibe ich doch selber. Ihr müsst es jetzt nochmal feststellen, um euch zu erheben und zu sagen, wir waren nämlich nicht naiv. Wir wussten alles schon vorher. Grauenvoll, dumm. Aber egal. Der Punkt für mich ist, dass meine Rolle bisher als Internet-Erklärer zum einen notwendig war auf einer bestimmten Ebene. Nicht so, wie ich sie gemacht habe, aber dass das jemand tut, war, glaube ich, sehr notwendig. Ich habe auch davon profitiert. Das muss ich immer wieder betonen, weil das ist jetzt keine Aufopferung gewesen, im Gegenteil. Aber ich glaube eben, dass ich einen Fehler machen würde, wenn ich sie nicht ändern würde. Der Fehler wäre viel größer, als dass ich früher mal gesagt habe, Internet ist geil, kommt mal her. Wenn ich jetzt nicht darauf reagieren würde, wenn ich jetzt, so wie viele Leute, auch sehr sachkundige Leute, so tun würde, als würde der Späß-Skandal mich im Grunde nicht so richtig was angehen. Ach, wir können es ja eh nicht ändern, also, ist ja egal, wegignorieren. Das würde ich für den viel größeren Fehler halten und das würde ich auch für fatal halten. Das ist eine Art Meteoriteneinschlag. Und im Erdbeben habe ich in Artikel geschrieben. Und ich kann einfach nicht so tun, als würde mich das Erdbeben nicht angehen, auch wenn ich derjenige bin, der vorher schon immer gesagt habe, da würde ein Erdbeben kommen. Das betrifft alle.
Eine Person, die zu denen gehört, die das alles schon immer gesagt haben, Evgeny Morozov, mehrere Bücher darüber geschrieben, der bekannt ist als Cyberskeptiker. Ich denke, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, aus Weißrussland kommt und dort einfach mal andere Staaten auch erlebt hat als jene, in denen wir jetzt aufwachsen, hat das quasi schon immer gesagt und ist jetzt ein häufiger Debattenpartner von dir. Und es ist jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich mir das anschaue, seine These, wenn ich sie eindampfen würde und vieles Wichtiges wegschneide, sage ich, er hat gesagt, ja, das Internet im gleichen Maße, wie es die Freiheiten der Vernetzung und der Verbindung ermöglicht, ermöglicht es auch die Möglichkeiten der Überwachung und diese werden genutzt. Und deswegen müssen wir vorsichtig sein mit dem, was wir da machen.
Ich habe ihn ein bisschen anders verstanden, aber du hast ja schon gesagt, dass du nur Teile davon darstellst. Zum einen vielleicht noch mal zur Einordnung häufiger Debattenpartner. Er hat eine Erwiderung auf mich geschrieben. Und wir waren auf Dreisatzkulturzeit, wo wir miteinander gesprochen haben. Ich will jetzt das Wort häufig anders benutzen, aber das musst du mir selber ausmachen. Tatsächlich finde ich seine Thesen sehr interessant. Und zwar nicht nur den Inhalt, sondern auch die Art und Weise, wie sie zustande kommen. Das wird in Deutschland nämlich häufig nicht gesehen. Gerade für die Leute, die da sehr schnell dabei sind zu sagen, ach, das ist einer von den Digitalskeptikern, die wollen unser blödes, schönes Internet kaputt reden. Er wird manchmal mit großer Häme überschüttet. Was man eindeutig feststellen kann, ist, dass Morozov eine sehr große Schärfe entwickelt hat. Fast eine Aggression in seinen Artikeln. Am Anfang, die ist inzwischen viel schwächer oder besser geworden, je nachdem, wie man es formuliert. Diese Schärfe rührt von einem ganz besonderen Grund her. In den Vereinigten Staaten ist diese Diskussion nämlich nicht so, wie man sie hier wahrnehmen kann, dass da eher alte Medien eher skeptisch berichten und versuchen, das alles mit so negativen Punkten zu belegen. Das kann man jetzt gut oder schlecht finden oder logisch. Das möchte ich mal dahingestellt sein. In den Vereinigten Staaten gibt es einen Diskurs, der sehr wirtschaftlich geführt wird und wo Silicon Valley, das Morozov immer benutzt, nicht nur von sich selbst, sondern auch von außen als eine Art Heilsbringer betrachtet wird. Das ist faktisch so. Und das kann auch jeder, der so ein bisschen nerdig unterwegs ist, so nachvollziehen, wenn man sich anschaut, wie da eine Star-Szene gebaut wird. Wie da eine Verehrungsszenerie gebaut wird. Am eingängigsten ist das bei Steve Jobs gewesen, wo man so quasi Superstar, Prophet, Magier, Gott oder was verehrt hat. Es gibt also in diesem großen Silicon Valley-Umkreis eine Tendenz dazu, einfach diesen ganzen Diskurs zu verklären, auf eine Art und Weise, die sehr aggressiv ist. Einfach zu sagen, das ist jetzt so, weil Internet, so hat das jedenfalls Morozov formuliert. Und am Anfang kannst du sagen, das ist aber nicht so, ich finde das anders. Und dann siehst du aber, dass dir Leute gegenüberstehen, die einfach unbegrenzt Geld haben und die Deutungsuheit in der Hand haben. Und ob die richtig liegen oder nicht, ist dahingestellt. Ich bin überhaupt nicht mit Morozov überall einer Meinung.
Ist das dein Handy, was da die ganze Zeit reinfunkt? Das wäre ganz hilfreich. Das kann man ja auch abgehört werden. Das wäre auch nicht so schön.
Das wäre ganz schlimm beim Podcast, wenn man abgehört werden würde, oder?
Morozovs Schärfe.
Morozovs Schärfe ist, glaube ich, eine Reaktion auf diese ungeheure Macht, das Geld und die Deutungsuheit, die sich da auf ein paar Quadratkilometern und um Silicon Valley ergeben haben. Und zwar völlig unabhängig davon, ob jetzt diese Botschaft, oder ihr nennt es Ideologie, die im Silicon Valley transportiert wird, ob die jetzt eine gute oder eine schlechte oder eine differenzierte oder im Einzelnen irgendwie wirksame Geschichte darstellt. Faktisch ist erst mal, dass er da etwas Aggressives dagegen setzt. Ich mache das jetzt vielleicht einfach mal beide Handys in den Flugmodus.
Ich fand das insofern ganz interessant, dein Artikel, als dass ich ja zur Eröffnung des Kongresses eigentlich genau auf derselben Fragestellung stand und eigentlich auch so einen ähnlichen Spinner geliefert habe.
Du hast Schock gesagt.
Schock habe ich gesagt, ich habe schlechter Traum gesagt und irgendwie Hollywood-Realität und noch ein paar andere Basselbörter. Und in gewisser Hinsicht meine ich so diese Frage, was jetzt? Das hat ja eigentlich auch diese ganze Hacker-Szene enorm umgetrieben. Zumindest war das spürbar, dass viele, die zum Kongress gekommen sind, die selbe Frage im Kopf hatten. Und jetzt? Das war wirklich das, was alles beherrscht hat.
Und jetzt muss man erstmal sagen, es ist eine Phase vorbei, was ich mit meinem Artikel eben auch versucht habe. Und zweitens, bestimmte Annahmen, die ich getroffen hatte, auf deren Grundlage ich agiert habe, haben sie sich als falsche herausgestellt oder jetzt in eurem Fall viel richtiger als gedacht. Es ändert sich etwas und jetzt brauchen wir einen Neuanfang. Und das ist das, was ich mit dem Debattenartikel wollte. Es gibt natürlich tausend Deutungen. Ich bin nicht der Freund davon, nachträglich noch zu sagen, ihr habt mich alle falsch verstanden. Das ist Unfug. Bei Debattenartikel werden nicht falsch verstanden, sondern die haben eine Funktion, einen Diskurs zu eröffnen. Man kann auch nicht einen Debattenartikel schreiben, wo alle denn davor sitzen und nicken. Ich habe zu dem NSA-Spielskandal häufig Aufklärungsartikel geschrieben, wo 90 Prozent der Leute, die das gelesen haben, gesagt haben, ja, stimmt. Scheiße, das stimmt, hat recht. Ja, richtig, richtig. Und so einen Kopfnicken verursacht haben. Das ist kein Debattenartikel. Da braucht dich also in der kontroverse Meinung eine, die ich auch emotional, wo ich dann einen emotionalen Druck hinterhabe. Aber das ist absolut richtig. Ganz viel aus meinem Artikel ist nicht wirklich neu. Ganz viel von dem, was ich geschrieben habe, liegt in der Luft. Du hast zwei Wochen vorher im Prinzip bei deiner Rede von einem Schockzustand gesprochen, Tim. Und dieser Schockzustand, ob man den jetzt Schock nennt oder Kränkung oder so eine Erschütterung, wie ich das auch getan habe, da können wir gerne über die Details reden. Da können wir gerne über die Details reden. Und da ist natürlich auch jeder anders in seiner Empfindung. Aber erstmal festzustellen, verdammt, wir können nicht mehr so weitermachen. Das ist für mich so immens wichtig. Und auch festzustellen, dass man in bestimmten Bereichen ihm nicht recht hatte. Dass man nicht immer recht haben möchte. Dieses grauenhafte, ich hab's schon immer gesagt, ich hab's schon immer recht gehabt. Wie kleingeistig, wie dumm und wie aggressiv nach innen gerichtet selbstreferenziell ist das denn? Ich hatte schon immer recht und ich werde auch immer recht haben. Und zwar vorträglich und nachträglich.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr froh, dass der Club nicht in so eine Told-You-So-Rhetorik abgeglitten ist.
Genau, dabei hätte es ja lustigerweise beim CEC gerade noch einen Grund gegeben dafür.
Ja, nie wäre es angemessener gewesen, das zu sagen, umso glücklicher bin ich, dass man es genau in dem Moment hat sein lassen. Das ist letztlich auch ein Zeichen der Stärke. Ich meine, die Hacker-Szene finde ich insofern besonders betroffen. Oder überhaupt ist das jetzt auch eigentlich erstmal der Ruf. Und man ist vorhin so, die Gesellschaft muss jetzt eine Antwort finden. Ich meine, wir reden von derselben Gesellschaft, die die ganze Zeit noch dabei ist, überhaupt zu verstehen, was das Internet eigentlich ist, beziehungsweise welche positiven Auswirkungen es auch für sich haben kann. Über die Negativen wird ja eigentlich genug lamentiert.
Ich glaube, überhaupt nicht. Ich finde, überhaupt nicht. Mitverlaub, darf ich dich da kurz unterbrechen. Ich glaube, über die negativen Eigenschaften wird genau, was du gesagt hast, lamentiert, aber sehr selten wirklich ernsthaft diskutiert. Die negativen, die positiven Eigenschaften werden halt immer von Leuten, wie ich auch einmal war und zum Teil auch noch bin, ich kann mich jetzt nicht komplett, völlig selbst verändern, ich brauche einen Optimismus, aber die positiven Eigenschaften werden schon auch so ein bisschen geschönt dargestellt, schon auch so ein bisschen, hey, hier, schaut mal, was wir Geiles da haben, macht das doch auch endlich. Über die negativen Eigenschaften wird nach meiner Auffassung viel mehr Lobby-Information betrieben, viel weniger Diskussionen, als es eigentlich sinnvoll wäre. Die Debatten sind da regelrecht vergiftet.
Ja, es geht mir nicht so sehr um diese Debatten oder Diskussionen darum, sondern für mich ist es eigentlich auch mehr eine Schlussfolgerung. Ich stelle einfach fest, es gibt für viele Leute in der Gesellschaft nicht so einen Zug zum Netz. Es gibt nicht so ein Gefühl, wo sie alle sagen, das ist jetzt unsere Gelegenheit, wo wir unsere Zukunft gestalten können. Das ist immer alles von Skepsis geprägt, das ist immer von Brauche ich das? Das ist verbreitet. Das mag sich wandeln, klar, das ist auch unvermeidbar, dass sich das wandelt, aber unabhängig davon, was öffentlich in Debatten gesagt wird, gibt es da einfach eine Zurückhaltung und die Gesellschaft ist schon noch dabei, diesen positiven Entwurf für sich überhaupt erst mal zu finden. Jetzt haben wir aber eben dieses Bekämpfen dieses Schockzustandes und ich denke, der ist jetzt vor allem auch erstmal eine Aufgabe der Techniker. Weil an vielen Stellen ist das Netz vor allem auch wirklich technisch gebrochen. Man hat das Netz gebaut in seinen grundfesten Annahmen, in sehr positiv optimistischen Annahmen.
Das ist glaube ich ein ganz klassischer Nerd-Trugschluss. Also jetzt, dass jetzt erstmal die Technik gefragt ist. Das ist halt so das Naheliegende. Es ist eben auch aus der Perspektive eines, jemandes, der diese ganze Technik eher beherrscht als andere Sphären. Das ist das Simpelste. Zu sagen, ich habe ja vorher gesagt, Infrastruktur sind viele Dinge kaputt. Die mangelnde Dezentralisierung des Internets ist etwas, was immer wieder angesprochen wird. Auch schon länger angesprochen wird. Die Anfälligkeit für Attacken. Also ich meine, es geht so und so viel Prozent, hoher zweistelliger Prozentbreit des Traffics geht halt über so ein nicht mal ein halbes Dutzend Untersee-Cabels. Das ist eigentlich aus jeder vernünftigen Sicht schlecht bis katastrophal, sowas auch nur überhaupt erstmal zu planen. Aber heute wissen wir eben auch, warum. Aber ich glaube eben nicht, dass die Technik gefragt ist. Ich glaube, dass die Technik eine Aufgabenstellung bekommen muss von einem Diskurs aus der gesamten Gesellschaft. Eigentlich muss da, und das ist das Schlimme, die Politik die Technik briefen, was am besten zu geschehen hat. Und der Grund, warum du jetzt lachst, der ist ein ganz schlimmer.
Ja, da muss ich jetzt wirklich ein bisschen lachen.
Genau, aber der ist ein ganz schlimmer. Weil die Politik einfach auf so vielen Ebenen so grotesken Quark gemacht hat in den letzten Jahren. Weil so große Teile der Politik sich freuen über Überwachung, weil sie glauben, sie müssten Kontrolle ausüben bis in die Jackentaschen der Leute hinein. Aber trotzdem glaube ich, Politik ist das Mittel der Gesellschaftsgestaltung, was wir jetzt zuerst brauchen. Dass die Politik das selbst noch nicht so richtig checkt und dass weite Teile der Politik einfach in der Pfeife zu rauchen sind, wenn es um die Zukunft des Internets ist. Da sind wir uns völlig einig. Aber ich glaube, es ist schwierig bis katastrophal, wenn man wagt, das sei ein technisches Problem und deswegen müssen jetzt erstmal die Techniker ran. Das ist ein falscher Mann.
Also die politischen Lösungen sehen wir doch aber jetzt schon. Also das sind ja die politischen Reaktionen, sehen wir. Sogar die Lösungen, die jetzt irgendwie in der Bundesrepublik angeboten werden. Ja, also E-Mail made in Germany als Beispiel. Das sind ja alles keine nennenswerten Reaktionen. Oder darüber zu diskutieren, dass man jetzt irgendwie ein Schengen-Netz macht. Wir müssen die Diskussion jetzt nicht wiederholen. Aber da sieht man ja die Grenzen der politischen Erwägungen zu technischen Fragen.
Falsch, völlig falsch. Nur weil die Politik jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren 57 grauenvolle und 117 katastrophale Vorschläge gemacht hat und anderthalb okaye und 0,7 gute. Nur deshalb heißt das nicht, dass die Politik das falsche Mittel ist. Im Gegenteil. Wir erleben, dass die Strukturen in der Politik nicht adäquat sind. Wir erleben, dass die Art und Weise, wie Politik gemacht ist, wenig sich auf Technologie bezieht. Wir erleben aber nicht, dass Politik das falsche Mittel ist. Ganz im Gegenteil. Ich glaube, wir brauchen, und da bin ich dann mit Mochosow sogar auf einer Ebene, obwohl wir wirklich in vielen Punkten nicht so auf einer Ebene sind, wir brauchen das richtige politische Eingreifen. Wir hatten ganz viel falsches politisches Eingreifen, aber wir brauchen das richtige politische Eingreifen.
Hat denn das Internet die Politik hervorgebracht oder die Politik das Internet? Ich meine, wenn du sagst, dass die Politik formt, ist überhaupt in der Lage, das Internet zu formen?
Nein, die Politik ist in der Lage, die Gesellschaft zu formen. Und die Gesellschaft baut sich in den meisten Fällen eine Umgebung, die ihren Zwecken dient. Das ist ein bisschen sehr vereinfacht. Aber vom Grundsatz her glaube ich nicht, dass es Zufall ist, dass man das Internet so gut zur Überwachung benutzen kann. Das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum ich gesagt habe, das Internet ist kaputt. Ich glaube, das Internet ist deswegen so gut zur Überwachung zu benutzen, weil an bestimmten Stellschrauben politisch schon vor vielen Jahren daran gedreht worden ist, um immer mal so ein bisschen die Entscheidung...
Okay, da will ich dir mal widersprechen. Und zwar in mehrererlei Hinsicht. Also, erstens glaube ich, wenn ich jetzt von den Technikern rede, dann rede ich jetzt nicht unbedingt von diesem weltfremden Ingenieur, der irgendwie alles nur in Volt und Ampere misst. Sondern ich rede hier wirklich von den Architekten des Internets. Von den Leuten, die dieses System in sich verstanden haben und die auch frühzeitig daraus diese... Ja, aber die gibt es.
Das Internet in sich verstanden haben, das ist...
Ja, bin ich gerade dabei. Also, die sozusagen festgestellt haben aus dieser Notwendigkeit, wie Computer gut miteinander verstehen, daraus dieses offene Netz und daraus auch eine eigene Kommunikationskultur geschaffen haben. Das ist ja das, was im Internet sich an vielen Stellen bahnbricht. Sei es die Art und Weise, wie man miteinander chattet, bis hin zu solchen Entwicklungen wie Twitter. All diese Dinge sind aus dem Netz von unten nach oben gekommen und nicht von oben politisch als Maßnahme festgelegt worden oder irgendeine technikferne Gesellschaft hat jetzt gestalterisch darauf eingewirkt, dass es sich zu entwickeln hat. Viele der kommunikationskulturellen Innovationen, wenn nicht sogar alle, sind tatsächlich Bottom-Up-Entwicklungen, die aus diesem Netz herauskommen.
Das ist deine Interpretation als Techniker.
Das ist nicht so sehr meine Interpretation als Techniker, sondern das ist auch so ein bisschen meine Interpretation als freiheitsliebender Mensch, der ich einfach einen gewissen Anspruch an die gesellschaftliche Entwicklung habe und die ich das Internet als potenziellen Geschmacksverstärker an der Stelle auch sehe, wie du das ja eigentlich auch gesehen hast. Aber das ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie vollkommen des Jungs sind. Die Politik wiederum ist ja immer noch dabei, nachzuvollziehen, wie denn das überhaupt funktioniert, wenn sie es überhaupt schon verstanden hat.
Das ist ein wahnsinnig plattes Beispiel. Die Politik hat besser begriffen als irgendjemand sonst, wie das Internet funktioniert, denn die Politik hat dafür gesorgt, dass milliardenschwere Apparate das Internet als Überwachungsmechanismus benutzen können. Zu einem Zeitpunkt, als wir noch froh waren, dass der Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten twittert, wow, geil, super ist es. Die Techniker haben es zugelassen, dass es möglich war. Zu dem Zeitpunkt haben die schon Milliarden reingesteckt, um das Internet, auch nicht nur, bin völlig einer Meinung, auch zu einer perfekten Überwachungsmaschinerie mit auszubauen. Das kann man doch nicht einfach wegdiskutieren. Nein, wir haben es aber auch zugelassen. Techniker lassen immer alles zu, wenn jemand vor ihnen steht und sagt, du kommst im Gefängnis, wenn du es nicht tust. Aber ich bitte dich, ich bitte dich.
Also Moment mal. Du hast gerade, kommen wir mal auf einen zentralen Punkt dieses Problems zurück. Dezentralität. Du hast gerade selber gesagt, Internet könnte sehr viel dezentraler sein. Die mangelnde Dezentralität ist eines der großen Probleme dieses Internets. Das heißt, wir beklagen eine, über die Jahre haben wir es gesehen, die großen Social Networks sind irgendwie das beste Beispiel, wo das Netzwerk Internet genutzt wurde, um an einer zentralen Stelle ein komplettes soziales Netz abzubilden. Also quasi sich vom Netzwerk Gedanken komplett zu trennen, indem man das vollständig zentralisiert. Diese Tendenzen zur Zentralisierung, die sind aber doch eher von der Wirtschaft gekommen als von der Politik.
Nein, nein, nein. Also was heißt eher von der Wirtschaft? Da muss man die Beziehung zwischen Politik und Wirtschaft ein bisschen aufdröseln. Es ist so, dass die Wirtschaft dazu neigt, die Spielräume der Politik auszufüllen und manchmal auch darüber hinaus zu agieren. Insofern ist natürlich das politisch gewollt, dass es zu solchen Zentralisierungen kommen kann. Und da sind soziale Netzwerke noch nicht mal das beste Beispiel. Vielleicht ist zum Beispiel die unfassbar geringe Zahl der Provider, der Level 1-Tier A, also jedenfalls der Supercarrier, die Zahl ist unter 10.
Das ist ja keine politische Maßnahme, das ist eine klare Konsequenz des Wirtschaftssystems.
Nein, das ist ein Rahmen, der politisch gesetzt wird. Dass es überhaupt dazu kommen kann, dass so wenige Unternehmen den Internetverkehr so massiv kontrollieren.
Das ist in jedem anderen Wirtschaftsbereich auch so. Du hast wenige Tageszeitungen, du hast wenige Automobilhersteller.
Wenn du dir anguckst, nein, nein, nein, das ist ein bisschen kurz gesagt.
Wenige Telefonanbieter, eine Bundespost.
Wenn du dir zum Beispiel anguckst, dass es ein Bestreben in der Energiewirtschaft geht, zurück zu Stadtwerken. Will sagen, dass ein Kraftwerk den Leuten gehört, mehr oder weniger den Leuten gehört, die davon Energie beziehen. Wenn du dir anguckst, die Rückkehr von bestimmten genossenschaftlichen Strukturen. Es ist kein Naturgesetz, dass alles so ist.
Bevor es diese Bestrebungen gab, wurde aber jahrelang nichts gemacht. Der natürliche Lauf der Dinge ist, dass wir... Es wurde nicht nichts gemacht.
Es sind aktive Entscheidungen. Es sind aktive Entscheidungen gewesen. Und du hast ja bestimmt in Internetgeschichte gut aufgepasst. Und da gab es einfach maßgeblich experimentisch in den 70er-Jahren, wie sollte ein Datennetz aufgebaut sein? Da gab es auf der einen Seite die ITU, die internationale Fernmeldeunion, die gesagt hat, wir brauchen eigentlich eine Art Datentelefonnetz. Telefonnetz, wahnsinnig, ein intelligentes Netz, wo die Teilnehmer dumm sind. Und dann gab es die Wissenschaftler, die gesagt haben, nein, wir brauchen ein dummes Netz, wo die Teilnehmer intelligent sind und auch, wo einfach nur Daten durchgeleitet werden. Zum Glück haben sich dann die Wissenschaftler durchgesetzt und nicht die ITU. Da gibt es ein paar interessante Experimente. Als irgendwann in den 70er Jahren ein fahrendes Auto auf dem Highway und ein Universitätsrechner miteinander vernetzt wurde und so weiter. Das ist alles Historie. Man kann daraus lernen, dass es eine politische Entscheidung war, dass das Internet so geworden ist, wie es geworden ist. Und nicht, dass es so eine Art Mischung aus BTX und Kabelfernsehen geworden ist. Das war eine politische Entscheidung. Sie ist vielleicht eher zufällig getroffen worden. Sie ist vielleicht auf Anraten von Technikern getroffen worden. Aber sie ist politisch getroffen worden.
Sie ist auch nicht von der ITU getroffen worden. Das Internet wurde tatsächlich einfach gebaut.
Die hat geglaubt, sie sei zuständig dafür. Es wurde nicht einfach gemacht. Wir können uns jetzt ewig in der Diskussion verfransen. Letztendlich ist es eine Philosophie. Die philosophische Frage, die dahinter steht, ist, ob es einen Idealzustand gibt, wo die Technik von alleine auf etwas hinsteuert. Oder ob man das von außen beeinflusst. Das ist eine Diskussion.
Entschuldigung, ich lasse mir nicht gefallen, meine These in die Richtung zu drücken. Der Punkt ist, die Zentralisierungstendenz ist meine These. Überall da, wo Geld zu verdienen ist, kommt sie zum Tragen. Das ist ein Naturgesetz unseres Wirtschaftssystems. Das ist ein Naturgesetz des Wirtschaftssystems.
Das ist ein Teil des Problems, dass du glaubst, es ist ein Naturgesetz.
Genau, und es wäre dann eine Möglichkeit der Politik dort gegenzusteuern. Das ist ja die gesamte Idee der Sozialdemokratie, zu sagen, wir wollen dieses freie Wirtschaftssystem. Die Teile dieses Wirtschaftssystems, die uns nicht gefallen, versuchen wir zu kompensieren.
Das ist jetzt nicht zwingend Sozialdemokrat, aber ich ahne, was du sagen möchtest.
Das ist schön, dass du mir wenigstens so weit zuhörst. Und du sagst, die Politik hätte schon früher diese Zentralisierungstendenzen in Anbietern und so weiter entgegenwirken sollen.
Ja, mit dem hätte sollen, möchte ich ein bisschen vorsichtig sein. Ich möchte mich auf die Zukunft fokussieren. Ich glaube, das ist wichtiger ist, raus zu sagen, was jetzt nötig ist. Und was ist jetzt nötig? Da gibt es einfache, schnelle, simple und falsche Antworten. Und da gibt es Antworten, die komplex sind und sehr lange dauern.
Und die soll jetzt die Politik ausarbeiten, damit die Techniker sie dann umsetzen.
Nein, du glaubst, dass die Politik aus drei Ministern besteht, die irgendwie ihre Mails ausdrücken. Nein, die Politik ist ein Instrument zur Gesellschaftsgestaltung. Politik ist nichts anderes. Du kannst es doch Demokratie nennen, wenn du unbedingt möchtest, weil dir den Begriff besser gefällt. Ich glaube, dass die Gesellschaft sich darüber einigen muss, wie man damit verfährt. Und das ist eine sehr schwierige Angelegenheit, weil viele in der Gesellschaft, die zwar eine laute Stimme haben und mitreden wollen, aber vielleicht nicht alles so richtig durchblicken, auch die einfachsten Sachen nicht, weil die trotzdem mit angehört werden müssen. Es ist halt eine verdammt komplexe Aufgabe. Aber ich glaube, die Politik muss jetzt versuchen, eine Debatte in Gang zu setzen. Und zwar, was muss man tun? Wie muss man darauf hinarbeiten, um die Ziele A, B und C zu erreichen?
Du hast gerade die Personen in der Fußgängerzone erwähnt, die gar nicht wissen, was überhaupt das Problem ist. Und du hast andererseits jene, die im Moment politischen Gestaltungsrahmen haben, in Form von Minister- oder Staatssekretärposten, zitiert als hilflos. Was muss ich jetzt ändern, damit das passiert, was du möchtest?
Zum einen brauchen wir eine sehr viel stärkere Aufklärung. Und das meine ich auf mehreren Ebenen. Dieser Snowden-Skandal ist ja noch nicht im Ansatz durchleuchtet und aufgeklärt. Da fehlen noch sehr viele Informationen. Da fehlen noch sehr viele Interpretationen von dem, was da eigentlich stattfindet. Da fehlt noch eine gesellschaftliche Deutung davon, warum das überhaupt so passiert ist. Ich glaube zum Beispiel, es geht durch die Politik quer so ein Riss durch. Das hat noch nicht mal richtig mit rechts und links zu tun, aber ein Riss von denjenigen, die glauben, man muss unbedingt die Bevölkerung kontrollieren, weil sie sonst Quatsch machen. Und denjenigen glauben, aber eigentlich kann man die Leute schon auch in Ruhe lassen. Nennen es eine Form von politischem Liberalismus oder so. Aber ich glaube, das sind die Fragen, die man jetzt klären muss. Denn, und das ist die Essenz von diesem Skandal, die Möglichkeiten der Technologie, die Menschen bis ins Detail hinein zu überwachen, die sind in den letzten zehn Jahren exponentiell gestiegen. Diese Möglichkeiten auch zu nutzen, die Frage hat sich vor 30 Jahren gar nicht gestellt. Sie stellt sich aber jetzt. Und da muss man anfangen zu überlegen, was ist Selbstzweck? Was ist Mittel zum Zweck? Was wollen wir damit erreichen? Ist das der richtige Weg? Und das ist eine Diskussion, die können wir nicht unter irgendwelchen Nerds führen. Ich bin ja auch nur so ein halber Drittel Nerd für Arme oder so. Aber die können wir weder nur in der Politik führen, noch nur unter Nerds, noch nur unter den Leuten, die irgendwie Internetsoziologie studiert haben. Die muss man zusammenführen. Und deswegen ist es ja so schwierig und so enttäuschend. Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt, wir brauchen einen digitalen Optimismus, weil so eine Diskussion kannst du nur führen, wenn du irgendwie glaubst, dass am Ende was Gutes rauskommt. Sonst kannst du sagen, ach, mir alles scheißegal. Ich miete jetzt irgendwie ein Häuschen in Brandenburg und fange an zu malen oder so. Ich weiß es nicht. Aber ich glaube, man muss, das erste, was man eingestehen muss, ist, dass diese Diskussion stattfinden muss.
Ich denke, ich habe deinen Punkt verstanden. Gut. Wir kommen zu dem, was jetzt in der Politik gerade geschieht. Präsident Obama hat reagiert auf den Skandal des Snowdans und hat mehrere Ankündigungen gemacht in einer lange erwarteten Rede und sagte, ja, ab sofort werden wir in unserer Telefonüberwachung nur noch zwei Hops mitnehmen. Statt drei. Statt drei. Es gab ein schönes Beispiel auf Heise. Ruf ein Terrorist den Pizzadienst, ist das eine direkte Verbindung, ruft der nächste Kunde den Pizzadienst, ist er einen Schritt entfernt, ruft dieser Kunde dann seinen Arzt an, ist er zwei Schritte entfernt. Also bis dahin. Würde der Arzt dann seinen Babysitter anrufen, der wird nicht mehr mit überwacht. Das war also so das Beispiel von Heise.
Das ist schon das digitale Equivalent von blühenden Landschaften. Ich meine, das ist doch einfach die Lösung, oder?
Also über die Obama-Rede habe ich ja auch auf Spiegel Online nochmal geschrieben. So meine Einschätzung, ich konnte sie noch nicht ganz durcharbeiten. Und zwar in dem Sinne durchlesen, klar. Durcharbeiten im Sinne von, dass man sich wirklich die einzelnen Formulierungen genauer anguckt. Es ist ja ein extrem interessantes linguistisches Problem geworden, zu verstehen, was bei der NSA wer warum wann sagt. Und zwar nicht nur bei der NSA, sondern eigentlich bei der Politik insgesamt. Das Phänomen ist ja ein politisches Phänomen, was sich bloß besonders verdichtet jetzt bei diesem Geheimdienstapparat äußert.
Nämlich, dass die Sätze so spezifisch sein müssen, dass sie immer wahr sind.
Das platte Beispiel ist irgendwie, dass jemand sagt, wir überwachen niemanden, weil Informationen sammeln, was anderes ist als überwachen. Das sagt er natürlich nicht dazu. Das ist so ein ganz einleuchtendes Beispiel. Ich habe angefangen, diese Obama-Rede mir genauer anzugucken. Und tatsächlich gibt es in beide Richtungen, sowohl in die positive Deutungsrichtung, als auch in die extrem negative Deutungsrichtung, Anknüpfungspunkte. Einen negativen Punkt habe ich versucht aufzuzeigen in meiner Spiele-Online-Kolumne. Nämlich, dass ernsthaft versucht hat, die NSA-Mitarbeiter so als das menschliche Ansatz der NSA.
Ja, das war wirklich furchtbar.
Das war Horror, das war grauenhaft. Man muss doch auch an die NSA-Mitarbeiter denken. Das sind auch Menschen, die haben auch Konten- und Patientendaten. Die haben auch Kinder, die auf Facebook und Instagram sind.
Sie müssen es ja eigentlich viel besser wissen.
Wahnsinn!
Dein Kollege hat ja richtig draufgehauen hier. Der Jakob Augstein seiner Kolumne, was du gelesen hast. Der Kaiser und seine Vasallen. Wo ja Obama da auch wirklich so ein kaiserhaftes Auftreten.
Ja, der Jakob Augstein verfolgt auch seine eigene Agenda. Ja, ja.
Du auch?
Ich auch. Schock!
Oh Gott, wir müssen die Sendung abbrechen.
Ja, ich versuche, meine Agenda so offen wie möglich zu folgen. Aber das ist eine zweite Sache. Wir auch. Worauf ich hinaus möchte. Der Kaiser und seine Vasallen hatte ich hier für ein wenig zielführendes Bild. Insgesamt, was ich für wesentlich zielführende halte, ist, wenn man mal diese Obama-Rede genau abklopft auf die problematischen Formulierungen. Ich bin damit noch nicht durch. Die ist ja auch gar nicht so kurz. Was ich schon mir angeguckt habe und was vielleicht sogar noch interessanter ist, wenn man jedenfalls außerhalb der USA ist, sind die Reaktionen da drauf.
Ich würde vielleicht gerne vorher nochmal kurz seine Ankündigung zusammenfassen. Also was er auch sagt, Ab sofort, Zugang zu vorratsdaten speichert, gespeicherten Vorratsdaten, nur noch mit richterlichem Beschluss.
Natürlich hinfälliger Quatsch, weil wir schon gesehen haben, wie Gerichte in den Vereinigten Staaten sagen, ach, diese 32 Millionen Leute wollt ihr überwachen? Okay, da werdet ihr schon Grund haben.
Dann hat er für viele andere Sachen erstmal nur Absichten erklärt. Das heißt, da werden jetzt keine sofortigen Änderungen stattfinden, sondern geht es darum, dass er seine Minister mit Ausarbeitung entsprechender Gesetzesvorschläge beauftragt hat. Und er möchte gerne die Verwaltungsaufsicht über die Geheimdienste stärken und regelmäßige Evaluierungen stattfinden lassen, aber nicht parlamentarisch.
Ja, das ist genau, das ist also, in den Vereinigten Staaten, das ist ja sowieso ein multiples Problem. Das gesamte politische System der Vereinigten Staaten ist, ich darf jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht kaputt sagen, dass nicht viele Leute wieder aufhören, aber es ist tatsächlich faktisch kaputt aus ganz vielen Richtungen. Ich halte die Vereinigten Staaten natürlich noch für eine Demokratie, aber strukturell sind da so viele Sollbruchstellen drin, dass man, fürchte ich, davon ausgehen muss, dass die Macht des Präsidenten über diesen Späherparat nicht so groß ist, wie man es sich wünscht. Und ich bin sehr traurig, sowas in Erwägung ziehen zu müssen. Ich habe das absichtlich...
War das für dich jetzt auch eine Neuigkeit?
Naja, was heißt eine Neuigkeit? Das war zumindest die Hoffnung, dass es nicht so sei. Und diese Hoffnung habe ich, glaube ich, mit vielen anderen Menschen geteilt. Immer davon auszugehen, dass im Hintergrund eine Geheimregierung eigentlich den Leuten sagt, was los ist. Das ist, glaube ich, nicht der richtige Ansatz, die Leute eher danach zu beurteilen, was passiert. Und zu sehen, dass der Präsident, und so würde ich es mich eher formulieren, bevor er im Amt war, durchaus sehr bürgerechtsorientiert gesagt und zum Teil gehandelt hat und nachdem er im Amt war, aus irgendeinem Grund x oder aus mehreren Gründen x, y, z, seine Meinung stark zurückgefahren hat, was zum Beispiel die Kontrolle der Geheimdienste angeht. Da kann man jetzt mehrere Schlüsse draus ziehen. Und ich möchte aber auch ein bisschen warnen, davor den Einfachsten zu ziehen, wie er hat gemerkt, dass er das nicht kann. Ich würde auch ein bisschen sagen wollen, in einem solchen Amt kann man bestimmte Notwendigkeiten erkennen. Das spielt sicher mit rein. Aber ich habe den Luxus, und den Luxus haben alle Leute, alle anderen Leute natürlich auch, das als egal zu betrachten, warum er ganz offensichtlich den Geheimdienst nicht so kontrollieren möchte, kann, darf, soll, wie es einer vernünftigen Demokratie angemessen wäre. Ich kann einfach als Fakt sagen, er tut es nicht. Und er tut es auf besorgniserregende Weise nicht.
Zwei Dinge, die er jetzt angekündigt hat, für den Foreign Surveillance Intelligence Court, ist, dass der Geheimdienstkoordinator jährlich jene Entscheidungen dieses Gerichtes, die einen weitreichenden Einfluss auf die Privatsphäre haben, überprüfen soll, ob man sie vielleicht veröffentlichen könnte. Also hier klares Bekenntnis zur Transparenz. Und damit das nicht nur einmal im Jahr passiert, möchte er regierungsunabhängige Fürsprecher in diesen Fisk reinsetzen, die eine unabhängige Stimme erheben dürfen. Natürlich werden die dann unter Geheimhaltung stehen und können dann nicht nachher da rausgehen und sagen, was sie da erlebt haben. Das heißt quasi, er wird sich da jetzt Leute reinsetzen, die das zarte Flänzchen der Privatsphäre hochhalten dürfen gegenüber diesem Gericht.
Es ist wirklich so eine Ladung Bullshit, die da gekippt worden ist.
Es ist insofern absurd, als dass die bisherigen Kontrollmechanismen auch schon nicht funktioniert haben. Und wenn ich mir Leute angucke, wie diejenigen, die in den Ausschüssen sitzen, um die NSA zu kontrollieren, die parlamentarischen, also sowohl aus dem Senat, wie auch aus dem Kongress. Die Jan Feinstein heißt, glaube ich, die eine Mike Rogers, das ist ein anderer Demokratin und Republikaner. Das sind Leute, die haben Sachen gesagt, da fasst man sich nicht mal an den Kopf, weil man nicht an den Kopf rankommt. Das sind Leute, die sollen eigentlich diese Maschinerie kontrollieren und sind doch nach ihren Äußerungen dazu überhaupt nicht willens, auch nur so was ähnliches wie Kontrolle auszuüben. Und wenn ich mir dann anschaue, wie in den Vereinigten Staaten tatsächlich immer wieder so einzelne Argumentationen hervorbrechen, wie ein Kongressabgeordneter, der ernsthaft gesagt hat, es ist doch kein Bruch der Privatsphäre, wenn man gar nicht mitbekommt, dass jemand in den eigenen Daten schnüffelt. Also wenn man merkt, was da für Narrative unterwegs sind, dann sieht man, die Problemlösung in den Vereinigten Staaten wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Ich möchte aber gleichzeitig hervorheben, weil es so viele Leute gibt, die jetzt ihren Anti-Amerikanismus voll auf die Hupe drücken und sagen, ja, stimmt, die Schweine. Ich möchte gleich hervorheben, dass es natürlich auch substanzielle Maßnahmen von der Zivilgesellschaft gibt und sogar von Teilen der Politik gegen diese Überwachung zu kämpfen. Und die auch, hoffe ich, einen größeren Erfolg haben werden als Hans-Peter Friedrich mit seiner Reise nach Washington, der bescheuertsten...
Okay, also ganz kurz, ich will es wenigstens jetzt, wenn wir es nicht angerissen haben. Justizministerium hat zwei Aufgaben. Sollen einmal irgendwie Beschränkungen für die Auswertungen von Kommunikation durch den Foreign International Surveillance Act ausarbeiten und die National Security Letters überarbeiten. Da soll es darum gehen, dass sie eventuell nicht die Unternehmen, die die jene empfangen, auf ewig zu Geheimhaltung verpflichtet sind, sondern dass man sie eventuell nach fünf oder zehn Jahren, oder nach 100 Jahren, das soll eben ausgearbeitet werden, dann ihnen erlaubt da auch was zu sagen. Unternehmen sollen unter Umständen Statistiken über die National Security Letters, die sie bekommen, veröffentlichen dürfen.
Unter Umständen dürfen sie das.
Das sind jetzt Ideen, das sind jetzt Anregungen für diese Überarbeitung.
Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass diese Anregungen dann auch noch in Ausschüssen verwässert werden, damit sie nicht... Ich meine, das ist schon am Anfang nichts, wird dann nochmal halbiert, dann in zehn Stücke geteilt und das kleinste davon wird zur Hälfte umgesetzt. Also ich meine, für mich ist aus dieser Obama-Rede relativ deutlich geworden, dass der politische Willen, ernsthaft an der Überwachungsmaschine zu ändern, das einfach nicht nur nicht vorhanden ist, sondern im Gegenteil. Das ist diese Aufdeckung des Späßskandals, nicht mal dazu beiträgt, darüber nachzudenken, ob das Grundmuster alle zu überwachen. Vielleicht eventuell nicht das Klügste sein könnte oder nicht das Beste sein könnte. Es gibt für mich keinen Grund anzunehmen, dass nicht substanzielle Teile der US-Politik, und da würde ich auch wirklich sagen der Politik und nicht der Apparate, in Überwachung und Kontrolle mehr oder weniger von allen Menschen auf dem Planeten ein richtiges und kluges und nützliches Gerät sehen. Und das Schlimme ist, das ist noch nicht mal in den Vereinigten Staaten nur so. Es gibt auch in Deutschland auf einer niedrigeren Ebene, das muss man zugestehen, durchaus diese Haltung in der Politik quer durch verschiedene Parteien, das ist nicht nur mal so ein rechts-links Ding, quer durch die Politik dieser Haltung. Irgendwie ist ja Kontrolle gar nicht so schlecht. Irgendwie muss man doch, und vielleicht hängen wir doch noch eine Kamera auf, damit noch ein bisschen mehr Überwachung da ist.
Da begegnet er ja auch den befreundeten Regierung, wo er sagt, die Spitzen von Staat und Regierung unserer Freunde sollen nicht mehr abgehört werden. Die Geheimdienstzusammenarbeit soll verstärkt werden. Die engsten Freunde übrigens. Die Geheimdienstzusammenarbeiten sollen verstärkt werden. Also ihr kriegt ein Stück von unserem Kuchen ab. Die Wirtschaftsspionage soll eingeschränkt werden. Und er wird einen Koordinator für internationale Diplomatie nominieren. Ich gehe dann davon aus, dass es dann derjenige, der da so die Gruppe, der sich einfach in dem Gespräch mit Hans-Peter Friedrich so gut hervorgetan hat, dass man ihm da jetzt eine Jobdescription draus macht. Und er sagt dann sogar, er betont ja sogar, um das klarzustellen, unsere Geheimdienste werden weiter Informationen über die Absichten von Regierungen, im Unterschied zu einfachen Bürgern, rund um die Welt sammeln, in der gleichen Weise, wie es die Geheimdienste aller anderen Nationen tun. Wir werden uns nicht dafür entschuldigen, dass wir vielleicht ein bisschen effektiver dabei sind als andere Regierungen.
Ja, da sind gleich mehrere narrative, höchst problematische Natur drin.
Darf ich das mal kurz zusammenfassen, diese Obama-Rede? Weil ihr jetzt alle so laut geschrien habt, bin ich mal kurz zu meinen Jungs gegangen. Und die haben gesagt, nee, das muss so sein. Geh mal vor die Kameras und versuch das mal zu erklären.
Ich glaube ernsthaft, dass Obama das so entscheidet. Ich glaube nicht an diese Verschwörungstheorie, dass im Hintergrund so Schatten-NSA, die eigentliche Regierung, das glaube ich nicht. Das glaubst du wirklich nicht? Nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist ja aber ein bisschen naiv von dir, oder?
Ja, ich bin so ein naiver Typ.
Nicht, dass du darüber dann auch wieder nochmal eine Kolumne schreiben musst.
Nein, nein, ich glaube, dass Obama, ach und wenn. Ich glaube, dass Obama das ernsthaft so denkt. Ich nehme ihm das ab, dass er, das ist der Subtext, den er nicht sagt, ich nehme ihm das ab, dass er wirklich denkt, nein, nein, wir müssen die überall überwachen. Ich glaube, dass er sich da so schon hineingefügt hat. Ich glaube auch, dass es ihm schwer bis gar nicht möglich wäre, das einzuschränken. Aber ich glaube auch, dass er den Willen dazu nicht hat.
Ich denke, das Problem, wenn du einmal die Rolle hast, für die Sicherheit einer Nation irgendwie zuständig zu sein, kannst du dir aussuchen, ob du in den Geschichtsbüchern stehen möchtest, als derjenige, der maximale Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergriffen hat und dem dann trotzdem irgendwie zwei Flugzeuge im Turm gelandet sind oder derjenige, der die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen verringert hat und dem dann deshalb zwei Flugzeuge im Turm gelandet sind.
Das ist das ein Problem. Ein anderes Problem, was häufig nicht so in den Vordergrund gestellt wird bei Obama, ist, dass er eine sehr präzise und auch gar nicht so ganz schlechte innenpolitische Agenda hat in vielen Punkten. Und dadurch, dass die Vereinigten Staaten zu 99,7 Prozent aus Innenpolitik bestehen und der außenpolitische Kram tangiert die Leute halt nur dann, wenn irgendwie Militär am Start ist und our troops supported werden müssen. Dadurch muss man auch außenpolitische Entscheidungen immer mit der Brille der Innenpolitik betrachten. Ich will sagen, Obama hat drei, vier, fünf Punkte, zum Beispiel Gesundheitsreform. Die möchte er innenpolitisch durchsetzen. Und damit er nicht noch mehr Baustellen woanders hat, damit er quasi sicher ist auf bestimmten Seiten, ist er dann in anderen Bereichen einfach total konservativ.
Aber ich meine, das könntest du im Prinzip von jeder Regierung sagen. Also es ist eigentlich fast in jedem Land so, dass die innenpolitischen Themen eigentlich dominierend sind. Ich würde es eher andersrum drehen, sogar dass die USA tatsächlich sehr viel mehr von außenpolitischen Faktoren abhängig sind, um innenpolitisch das machen zu können, was sie gerne tun wollen und wie sie hinwirken. Naja, ich meine, schau dir die Abhängigkeiten an vom Öl, von der Energieversorgung.
Erstmal mehr Öl zuhause produziert als importiert.
Ja, aber die existieren halt und das sind ja auch, sagen wir mal, Maßnahmen, die sie ergriffen haben. Aber auch ihre ganzen Kriege und ihre Einflussnahmen in Zonen hängen nicht nur, aber eben auch damit sehr stark zusammen. Das heißt, sie haben einfach da ein außenpolitisches Risikokapital rumliegen. Das ist jetzt nicht so unwichtig, dass das die amerikanische Öffentlichkeit nicht so wahrnimmt. Das sei dem unbenommen.
Ja, also ich glaube, wir verzetteln uns noch ein bisschen in Seitenahmen der Diskussion und der Interpretation.
Ja, dann lass uns das einfach mal nicht tun. Bist du denn mit der Zusammenfassung der Rede soweit durch oder gab es da noch irgendeinen Aspekt? Ich hab das nicht er tragen.
Es gab noch den Aspekt, dass er die Datensammlung, die Vorratsdatensammlung dezentralisieren möchte.
An die Unternehmen auslagern, um ganz genau zu sein.
Genau, das hab ich ein bisschen anders verstanden, dass ihm dieses deutsche Modell dann doch nicht so ganz behagt. Also insbesondere unter dem Problem, dass jetzt ja Edward Snowden auch kein Regierungsangestellter mehr war, scheint ihm das auch nicht so ganz zu behagen, das an die Unternehmen zu geben. Deswegen möchte er auch da dann mal etwas ausarbeiten lassen, hat sich da noch nicht ganz festgelöst.
Ja, da dann mehreren Punkten der Rede darauf Bezug genommen bzw. dieses Thema gestriffen. Spannend fand ich die eine Stelle, wo er gesagt hat, dass bestimmte Art von Metadaten eben bei den Unternehmen gespeichert werden soll, bleiben sollen, wo sie ohnehin anfallen. Warum finde ich das spannend? Weil das ein Narrativ ist, was auch in Deutschland benutzt wird im Kontext der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Wo man so einen wahnsinnig großen Unterschied macht, ob das jetzt ein Unternehmen auf den Servern hat oder der Staat auf den Servern hat. Was ich für problematisch halte aus mehrererlei Hinsicht, das zugrunde liegende Modell dahinter, der Gedankengang ist, auch in Deutschland habe ich das sehr häufig gehört, die Daten fallen doch eh an. Die Daten fallen doch eh an. Und ich glaube, dass die Daten fallen doch eh an, das Schlimmste ist, was man bei der Weiterentwicklung des Internets überhaupt sagen kann. Ich schaue mir so ein ganz normales Handy an. Dieses Handy, da hat mich neulich ernsthaft eine kleine App, die jeder kennt, die alle benutzen, alle sind begeistert nach Shazam. Fragt mich, ob Shazam jetzt nicht immer an sein soll, um Musik auch zu erkennen, wenn man nur zufällig dran vorbeigeht. Ja, es gibt natürlich, von Samsung hat das im letzten Jahr auf den Markt gebracht, diese Augenkontrolle, dass man mit den Augen was steuert. Das ist eine Kamera. Das mit dem Shazam-Ding, da gibt es auch tausend andere Apps. Es ist natürlich dann ein Mikrofon. Das bedeutet, die Technologie schreitet weiter voran und es ist überhaupt gar keine Frage mehr, dass in naher Zukunft alle Daten irgendwo anfallen. Und wenn man dann davon ausgeht, die Daten fallen doch ohnehin an, dann kommt man in Teufelsküche. Dann kommt übernächstes Jahr irgendwie das iPhone Health oder so und da ist so ein kleiner Tüser in den Daumen rein und das zapft so das Blut ab und sagt dir, was für Krankheiten hat er, die Daten fallen doch ohnehin.
Das Patent hat Apple schon. Überwachung von Körperfunktionen zur Erkennung des Nutzers.
Man darf doch nicht, wo es überall Patente drüber geht, wenn man da reingeht, dann reicht da eine Kränkung gar nicht aus. Also was ich sagen möchte, das ist genau so ein Narrativ, was ja problematisch ist. Die Daten fallen doch eh anhaltlich für katastrophal. Und deswegen braucht das ja eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion darum. Wie kann man dem begegnen? Sehr schwer, muss man dazu sagen. Es ist nicht leicht, dem zu begegnen. Das hängt natürlich zum Beispiel an einer guten Verschlüsselung. Es hängt an der Art und Weise, wie man politisch vorschreibt, wo Datenverarbeitungen zu geschehen haben. Muss ich jetzt zum Beispiel das, was auf diesem Handy passiert, anonymisieren, bevor es auf den Server kommt, verschlüsseln, bevor es auf den Server kommt? Darf das überhaupt nur auf dem Gerät verarbeitet werden? Macht das in Zukunft noch einen Unterschied? Das sind alles Fragen, die geklärt werden müssen. Und da glaube ich, dass deswegen brauchen wir die Politik. Deswegen brauchen wir nicht die Technologie und die Nerds, sondern die Politik, die dann am Ende der Technologie sagt, wie sie gefällig zu sein hat. Bisschen vereinfacht, das gebe ich dir.
Ich nehme deine These so an, und ich nehme sie zur Kenntnis, und du hast sie jetzt vertreten. Du tust aber dabei so, als hätten wir keine Datenschutzbeauftragten auf Bundesebene, auf Länderebene.
Das große Hoffnung, das Hoff-Hoss-Hoff.
Nein, nein, ich habe überhaupt keine Hoffnung. Ich sage nur, also deine These hört sich so an, als hätte sich da nie jemand bisher Gedanken darüber gemacht.
Nein, das nicht, das überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, wir haben sehr viel und sehr große Portionen der völlig falschen Politik gehabt. Und deswegen nehmen wir an, dass die Politik sei ein grundsätzlich ungeeignetes Mittel. Und das glaube ich eben nicht. Und das ist übrigens bei unserem nächsten Thema, der Netzneutralität ganz deutlich sichtbar.
Genau, wir kommen zur Netzneutralität, die in den USA jetzt eine leichte Einschränkung durch ein Bundesberufungsgericht erfahren hat. Das muss 2010 oder 2011 gewesen sein, als die FCC in den USA Netzneutralität reguliert hat. Und gesagt hat, okay, wir wollen, wenn ihr Einschränkungen am Traffic der Nutzer vornehmt, dann müssen die Regeln, nach denen ihr das macht, transparent sein. Erste Bedingung für Einschränkungen im Netz. Sie haben nicht gesagt, es gibt keine Einschränkungen im Netz. Sie haben gesagt, wenn ihr das macht, muss transparent sein.
Was meinen Sie damit, dass es dokumentiert öffentlich ist?
Dokumentiert für den Nutzer zugänglich sein muss. Mit anderen Worten, es muss irgendwo in den AGB stehen, Voice-over-IP wird geblockt. So kann man das bösartig lesen. Sie haben dann gesagt, legale Inhalte dürfen nicht gesperrt werden. Was schon mal interessant ist, weil das eben genau dieses Voice-over-IP-Sperren verhindern würde. Und Sie haben gesagt, was etwas unscharf formuliert ist, es darf keine unangemessene Diskriminierung stattfinden, was denke ich mal nur angemessen ist. Nur angemessen, ja. Und ich habe jetzt gerade das Beispiel Voice-over-IP schon genannt. Da haben Sie dann, was noch nicht so viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat, sowieso wireless networks, also kabellose Funknetze, vollständig von ausgeschlossen. Das heißt, die Netzneutralitätsregulation der FCC in den USA galten nur für Kabelnetze, nicht für Mobilfunknetze. Und Verizon, ein großer Netzanbieter, hat jetzt dagegen geklagt. Das landete eben vor diesem Bundesberufungsgericht. Und dieses hat geurteilt, dass die Punkte 2 und 3 dieser Regulierung unzulässig sind. Das heißt, es dürfen legale Inhalte gesperrt werden. Und es darf unangemessen diskriminiert werden. Und die FCC zieht sich jetzt zurück und prüft alle Möglichkeiten, sich dagegen zu wehren. Wir hatten gerade im Vorgespräch schon kurz überlegt, auf welcher Höhe dieses Gericht jetzt angesiedelt ist. Ich kriege das in Deutschland schon kaum hin. Welches Gericht gegenüber welchem Berufungs- und sonst was fähig ist. Aber die FCC scheint also noch Möglichkeiten auszuloten, sich dagegen zu wehren. Zu Grunde lag natürlich die Grundfrage, ob die FCC sich da überhaupt einmischen sollen dürfte oder nicht. Und die Urteilsbegründung lief mir nicht vor.
Da siehst du ja, das ist die Frage, ob die Politik in dem Fall durch die Behörde FCC vertreten oder die Wirtschaft, also die Privatwirtschaft, Taktgeber sein sollte. Da sieht man am Punkt der Netzneutralität ganz fantastisch, wie wichtig es ist, dass die richtige Politik, nicht die falsche dumme nervige Lobby, sondern die richtige Politik, die in meinen Augen davon gekennzeichnet ist, dass sie den Bürger als Auftraggeber und die Interessen des Bürger als Auftraggeber am ehesten versteht, dass die richtige Politik durchaus reguliert. Netzneutralität ist, glaube ich, nicht anders möglich, als wenn sie durch die Politik garantiert wird. Wenn man alle Regulationen zurückziehen würde, dann hätten wir übermorgen keine Netzneutralität mehr, weil alle Provider mit Kusshand sofort sagen würden, ja, also YouTube, wenn du jetzt noch deine Filme bei uns durchschleusen möchtest, dann musst du richtig auf Facebook auch. Und ach, die kleinen Videoplattformen, ja, die können das sich dann nicht mehr leisten. Das tut uns aber leid. Ich will sagen, fantastisches Beispiel Netzneutralität für etwas, was nur mithilfe der Technologie, mithilfe der Politik stattfinden kann, die der Technologie sagt, wie sie gefälligst ihren Kram hinzukriegen hat. Ja, das ist jetzt eine mutige These. Ich würde sagen, es ist eine Grundmuster, wie man das verstehen möchte. Bei der Netzneutralität, die ich übrigens für das zweitwichtigste Thema nach dem Späh-Skandal halte, bei der Netzneutralität ist das besonders evident, weil dort die offensichtlichen Unternehmensinteressen der Leute, die die Infrastruktur gebaut haben, den Anforderungen an die Zukunft widersprechen. Ich habe das jetzt absichtlich sehr kompliziert formuliert.
Ich freue mich, dass du genau das sagst, was ich gerade gesagt habe, dass es die wirtschaftlichen Interessen sind, die dieses Netz erst mal gestalten und die gebändigt werden müssen durch die Politik.
Naja, aber im Bereich der Netzneutralität würde ich dir ein bisschen widersprechen wollen. Aber ein cleverer Schachzug, dass du, ich sage das Gegenteil von dir, und du sagst dann, dass ich dich bestätigt hätte. Wir können das später ausfechten. Was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, beziehen wir das auf Deutschland. Ich glaube, es führt fast keinen Weg daran vorbei, dass der Staat massiv in eine Glasfaserinfrastruktur investiert. Wie das zustande kommt, in welchem Wechselspiel und dass da nicht Beamte irgendwelche Leitungen verlegen, ist auch klar. Wie die Unternehmen damit zu tun haben, wie das anschließend vermarktet wird. Das sind alles Sachen, die kann man diskutieren. Aber ich glaube, es ist eine vergleichsweise realistische Schätzung, dass Deutschland, um wirklich alle Glasfaser zu verkabeln, ungefähr 100 Milliarden Euro bräuchte. Das ist ein unfassbar großer Wert, auch wenn das seit der Euro-Krise einfach sich anhört wie so zwei Tagesrate oder so was. Aber diese 100 Milliarden Euro, gibt doch Schätzung von 30, 70, 80, diese 100 Milliarden Euro, die können nach meinem Dafürhalten nicht ernsthaft von Unternehmen aufgebracht werden. Ich will sagen, man kann nicht aus der Wirtschaft erwarten, dass die diese 100 Milliarden Euro in die Hand nehmen, dieses Netz hinlegen und anschließend mit ihren DSL-Anschlüssen warten, bis das Geld wieder drin ist. Natürlich wird jemand, der so viel Geld investiert, alles versuchen, und zwar buchstäblich alles, um irgendwie das Geld wieder rauszupressen. Ich glaube aber, dass das schädlich für die Nutzen als Netzneutralität wäre. Aus dem Grund glaube ich, dass ein Teil der Netzneutralität auch dadurch garantiert werden kann, indem man den Ausbau von Internetinfrastruktur staatlich fördert und gleichzeitig festschreibt, dass jeder, der an dieser Förderung teilnimmt, Netzneutralität gewährleisten muss bei der Vermarktung in Zukunft. Das ist jetzt einer von den Gedanken, die ich ausformuliert habe. Tim ist begeistert. Sein Gesichtsausdruck ist voller Glück und Freude.
Ich warte nur darauf, dass du deinen Redeschwall beendet hast, damit ich dann vielleicht nochmal einsteigen kann. Aber du hast an der Stelle völlig recht. Ich meine, die Netzneutralität ist einfach eine hochpolitische Frage, weil es einfach wirklich Wirtschaftsregulation ist. Natürlich.
Aber das habe ich ja nicht gesagt. Also die Frage, die ich jetzt herausfahre und die ich für die Politik an der Stelle sehe und was ich glaube, warum die Politik sich da gegen diese Netzneutralität positioniert und positionieren wird, ist, dass der messbare Wert einer Netzneutralität für die Gesellschaft nicht so eindrucksvoll vertreten werden kann wie die wirtschaftlichen Interessen der Unternehmen.
Das ist eine These, die in der Öffentlichkeit Bestätigung findet. Und das ist leider ein Grundmuster der Diskussion über Technologie, dass bestimmte, absolut essenzielle Bedingungen, Entwicklungen, Technologien, Voraussetzungen schwer zu erklären sind, dass man schwer sagen kann, warum sie denn jetzt für die einzelnen Personen auf der Straße so wichtig sind und dass sie anschließend noch viel schwieriger emotional aufzuladen sind. Bei der Netzneutralität gibt es auch noch eine Facette, die bisher sehr wenig besprochen worden ist. Es gibt nämlich unterschiedliche Brüche der Netzneutralität. Ich weiß noch nicht, ob die einzelne Namen haben. Ich habe das irgendwann mal positive und negative Netzneutralität genannt, aber das ist nicht besonders günstig. Einer der großen Verfechter der Netzneutralität, Pro-Netzneutralität, war ja in den Vereinigten Staaten Facebook. Kein Wunder, an bestimmten Tagen im Herbst macht Facebook so gut 40% des Traffic aus. In den Vereinigten Staaten habe ich irgendwo gelesen. Jedenfalls das Handy-Traffic zum einen. Aber natürlich sind diese Leute, die Unternehmen, die wahnsinnig große Datenmengen bewegen müssen, die finden die Netzneutralität gut und richtig. Nun ist es aber so, dass auf einer ganz anderen Ebene, Facebook selbst, die Netzneutralität massiv bricht. Und diese andere Ebene könnte sehr wichtig und interessant werden. Ich würde dich dazu mal ganz kurz bitten, ich bin ja leider nicht online, ich muss die Handys ausschalten, Tim, mal nachzugucken, was Jimmy Wales auf dem DLD gerade gesagt hat, als Ankündigung. Es geht darum, dass er bei Wikipedia mit Carian zusammenarbeiten möchte, um Wikipedia überall verfügbar zu machen, auch für Leute, die jetzt nicht so und so weiter.
Hatten wir letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen. Wikipedia-Gratiszugang in Entwicklungsteilern.
Katastrophal. Katastrophal. Warum ist das katastrophal? Das ist die gleiche Taktik, die Facebook anwendet. Es gibt ja diesen Zugang, den kennt ihr wahrscheinlich, 0.facebook.com, wo man auch ganz ohne zu bezahlen auf Facebook immer sein kann. Das ist auch ein Bruch. Das ist auch ein Bruch der Netzneutralität. Und das ist eine Diskriminierung der anderen. Und wenn man das jetzt weiterdenkt, auch durch diese in meinen Augen sehr schlimme Ankündigung von Wikipedia, dann gibt es irgendwann einen Netz, in das du kostenlos reinkommst. Wikipedia, Facebook. Du kannst ja aussuchen, wer noch dazu. Und wer irgendwann einen Vorteil davon hat. Und es gibt ein Netz, für das du bezahlen musst. Und dann bist du genau auf eine andere Art und Weise, aber genau an dem Punkt angekommen, der das Horrorszenario wäre für die Aufhebung der Netzneutralität. Nämlich, dass du kein freies und offenes Netz mehr hast, sondern ein 2-, 3-, 5- oder 38-Klassen-Netz. Und um das eine dazu zu buchen, musst du halt auch noch das bezahlen. Und um das andere dazu zu buchen, musst du auch noch das bezahlen.
Und das sich von Anbieterseite so gestaltet, dass man einfach für einen bestimmten Preis eben in das Klasse 1 für alle gratis Netz oder in das Klasse 2 für hat immerhin eine Marktpenetration von 60% Netz sich einkaufen kann.
Die Spekulationen sind schon vergleichsweise alt. Es gab ja schon vor zehn Jahren mal so eine große Protestwelle, oder vor fast zehn Jahren eine große Protestwelle gegen die Aufhebung der Netzneutralität. Ich erinnere da nur an die Tubes, die damals von einem über 90-jährigen Senator ein Spiel gebracht wurden, die verstopft seien. Aber der Punkt, der für mich daran relevant ist, die Netzneutralität wird von verschiedenen Seiten attackiert. Die wird von verschiedenen Interessen attackiert. Es ist nicht so leicht auszumachen, wo wer an welcher Front kämpft. Erst recht nicht bei den Unternehmen. Facebook scheinbar pro Netzneutralität, weil wenn sie für ihren Traffic bezahlen müssten, dann könnten sie morgen ihre Aktien an der Börse irgendwie abgeben.
Facebook ist natürlich, es kommt die Schwelle. Du wirst zum großen Unternehmen, das sich eventuell irgendwann leisten könnte, auch für Traffic mehr zu bezahlen. Und wenn du dann nochmal die Schwelle überschreitest, zu einem so großen Inhalteanbieter zu werden, dass du wiederum gegenüber den Carrierern eine starke Verhandlungsposition hast. Also ein Gratis-Netz, in dem ich kein Facebook bekomme, interessiert ja keine Sau. Also diese Position, wenn du irgendwann einmal an der Größe bist, hast du natürlich auch wieder ein Interesse daran, dass Netzneutralität aufgegeben wird. Oder kann dir egal sein, weil nur deine Konkurrenten darunter leiden würden.
Ich glaube, so simpel ist es nicht. Es ist ein naheliegender Schluss. Ich glaube nicht, dass er so einfach ist. Was aber sich zeigt, ist, dass Facebook zunächst vermeintlich für Netzneutralität ist, dann aber selbst an anderen Stellen dagegen arbeitet. Ich glaube eben, dass das sehr gut zeigt, dass das Thema Netzneutralität ein politisch sehr kompliziert zu beackern des Feldes ist, obwohl es technisch gar nicht so komplex ist. Ich weiß, dass die verschiedenen Datenklassen und Quality of Service und Blatt, da kann man viel drum herum diskutieren. Und ich weiß, dass es auch Positionen gibt im CCC. Da hat man sich eine Zeit lang nicht so ganz einfach damit getan, einfach die Netzneutralität so radikal durchzufordern. Schon weil einfach Leute dabei waren im CCC, die selber gemerkt haben, ja, wenn wir jetzt alles öffnen, dann ist alles voller P2P-Traffic und die anderen haben keine Brandbreite. Also solche Sachen, das sind ja legitime Argumente, warum man Daten dann am Ende doch wieder ein bisschen unterschiedlich behandelt. Aber auf einer übergeordneten Ebene ist Netzneutralität technisch gar nicht so komplex. Und trotzdem ist es eine sehr schwierige Diskussion.
Die jetzt ja geführt werden muss, aber wir hatten das in der letzten Sendung im Gespräch mit Thomas ausführlich gemacht. Deswegen bewegen wir uns kurz dem Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgossip zu.
Ja, unsere Bundesregierung ist sehr entschlussfreudig auf den ersten Metern ihrer neuen Selbstfindung.
Ja, was war geschehen? Heiko Maas wurde eigentlich noch gelobt, weil er gesagt hat, ich schreibe jetzt keine Vorratsdatenspeicherungsrichtlinie, solange ich keinen Urteil aus Europa gesehen habe, aus Brüssel gesehen habe.
Ich glaube, das Urteil kommt dann aus Den Haag, oder?
Siehst du, war klar, dass ich die beiden Städte wieder...
Ich kann aber auch Brüssel sagen, ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wo der Zettel sitzt.
Er hat gesagt, er wartet auf das EGH-Urteil. Und dann war das Innenministerium erstmal gar nicht so begeistert von dieser Äußerung. Es fand dann ein Gespräch statt, offensichtlich zwischen Heiko Maas und Thomas de Maizière. Aus dem Thomas de Maizière herausging und sagte, das fand ich schon sehr interessant, wie er da rausgegangen ist, und sagte, ja, wir haben uns geeinigt, aber ich überlasse das dem Heiko Maas, das der Presse mitzuteilen. Ich überlasse ihm diese Schmach, überlasse ich ihm. Ich gehe jetzt nicht raus und sage, ich habe ihn zurechtgewiesen, sondern die Suppe, die er uns da eingegossen hat, die wird er auch ganz alleine auslösseln und kann sich jetzt vor die Presse stellen und erklären.
Manchmal sieht man eben doch, dass Heiko Maas quasi in der Bundespolitik noch, im Vergleich zu dem, was er neu ist, und de Maizière, den ich übrigens schätze auf mehreren Ebenen, schon ein ziemlicher Fuchs und nicht besonders unklug agiert. Das sieht man ja an solchen Details dann doch auch. Das allgemeine Problem mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist, dass es in der neuen Regierung viele Fans der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gibt.
Wie ist denn jetzt die neue Sprachregelung?
Die neue Sprachregelung ist, dass man sagt, okay, er kann in der Zwischenzeit nicht untätig rumsitzen. Es gibt ja diese, oh, wer war es? Pedra Villaluz, der Name war so kompliziert, dass die Meinung des...
Europäischen Staatsanwalts.
Europäischen Staatsanwalt, der sie da formuliert hatte, wovon auszugehen ist, dass der Europäische Gerichtshof dieser Meinung folgen wird. Es gibt außerdem das Urteil des Bundesgerichtshofes. Und da steckt ja ein groben Rahmen ab, in dem sich eine zukünftige deutsche Richtlinie bewegen muss. Und Heiko Maas wird jetzt dann schon Ende dieses Monats damit beginnen, eine Richtlinie zu formulieren, die sich in diesem Rahmen bewegt, auf das sie sehr schnell dann dem demokratischen Verwertungsprozess zugeführt werden kann, sobald das Urteil des EuGH gesprochen und...
Das ist doch eine totale Nebelkerzennummer, oder?
Nee, das ist der Versuch, rein politisch, das hat mit dem Thema null zu tun. So eine Art Gesichtswahrung zu ermöglichen. Also faktisch, ich kann ja vielleicht mal meine Einschätzung zum Besten geben. Das Hauptproblem ist, dass in der Regierung mächtige Leute sitzen, die die Vorratsdatenspeicherung total toll und richtig und gut finden. Punkt. Das muss man erstmal feststellen. Sigmar Gabriel findet die gut. Der will die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Frau Merkel hat ihren Wunsch, das zu wollen, an Leute delegiert. Der Innenminister sowieso.
Frau Merkel will nie, die lässt wollen.
Ja, lässt wollen ist ein sehr guter Begriff. Aber ich war eher überrascht, positiv davon, dass mit Heiko Maas jemand sich quasi geoutet hat als Vorratsdatenspeicherungsgegner. Davon bin ich erst mal positiv überrascht. Was ja im Kontext Internet von der SPD positiv überrascht zu werden, ist ja eine ganz schöne Leistung auch überhaupt erst mal. Aber, und das ist für mich ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, dahinter steht für mich noch was ganz anderes. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und die vielen Leute, die so überzeugt von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung sind, die müssen meiner Meinung nach das tun, was ich auch getan habe, um es mal platt zu formulieren. Die müssen sich fragen, ob nicht dieser Spärskandal etwas Grundsätzliches verändert hat. Ob dieser Spärskandal nicht ganz grundsätzlich dazu führen müsste, über Überwachung und die Wirkung von Überwachung, die Art und Weise und die Instrumente der Überwachung völlig neu nachzudenken. Und meine Hoffnung ist, dass da tatsächlich ein Nachdenkprozess stattgefunden haben könnte. Und ich sehe es an klitzekleinen Äußerungen dazwischen. Aber ich gebe zu, das ist eine extrem fromme Hoffnung. Ich bin aber trotzdem nicht völlig überzeugt davon.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt. Ich meine, anfangs hast du ja noch große Schockzustände ausgemacht, die jetzt dieser Spärskandal... Was ist das für ein Wort? Wieso sagst du Spärskandal, wenn Sie nicht in anderen Termen ausdenken können?
Ich arbeite gerade an einem anderen Begriff. Es ist nicht so leicht.
Naja, auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, dieser Schock sitzt nur sehr oberflächlich. Und teilweise wird er auch sehr schauspielerisch vorgetragen. Gerade diese Empörung, diese Merkel-Abhörung, das war wirklich der Moment, wo ich so inhaltlich komplett zusammengeklappt bin. Dieser Pivot, der da irgendwie durchgeführt wurde nach dem Motto, eben gab es noch gar keine Affäre. Und jetzt empören wir uns kollektiv aufs Äußerste, aber bloß für eine Woche, weil eigentlich wollen wir das Thema ja vom Tisch haben, aber jetzt müssen wir uns ja empören, weil sonst verlieren wir das Gesicht komplett. Bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, also ich kann das mit dieser Einsicht nicht richtig feststellen.
Nein, nein, es geht nicht um Einsicht, sondern...
Meine Erläuterung, also mein Eindruck ist halt einfach, dass die Politik nicht da wirklich eine eigene Agenda hat. Also die wollen das nicht, sondern sie kriegen wieder gesagt, dass das ja wichtig sei. Und diese Stimmen reißen halt so nicht ab. Und selbst wenn sie das jetzt meinen, vielleicht auch anders sehen zu wollen, dann tun sie es halt trotzdem.
Ja, das Hauptproblem ist da sogar noch ein Übergeordnetes. Nämlich, dass man in diesem ganzen Sicherheitsapparat, Überwachungsapparat, und zwar völlig unabhängig von Geheimdiensten, sondern erstmal so auf Behörden bezogen, also auf alle Staatsorgane und deren angrenzenden Dienstleister, die mit Sicherheit und Überwachung zu tun haben, dass man dort sehr allergisch auf Evaluation reagiert. Das ist eigentlich absurd im Klartext. Wenn mir der Polizeipräsident sagt, wir brauchen das, dann brauchen wir das. Und dann ist auch völlig egal, ob das renommierte Max-Planck-Institut 2012 im Januar vorgestellt hat, dass es praktisch keinen Nachweis dafür gibt, dass Vorratsdatenspeicherung eine verbesserte Aufklärungsquote hat. Und ich meine, das Max-Planck-Institut ist jetzt wirklich nicht irgendwer. Und dann ist auch völlig egal, dass bei dem Verfahren vom Europäischen Gerichtshof, das der Gerichtshof selbst angedeutet hat, dass er vielleicht nicht so Töfte fand, wie jetzt die Leute versucht haben, den Gerichtshof zu überzeugen von der Notwendigkeit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Und dann ist auch völlig egal, dass man ganz viele Beweise dafür hat, dass das große Geld, was die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kostet, nicht nur vom Staat, auch von den privaten Unternehmen, dass das große Geld in anderen Bereichen viel effizienter eingesetzt werden könnte. Dann kann man also diesen ganzen evidenzbasierten Kram in der Pfeife rauchen, wenn jemand aus der Sicherheitsbehörde sagt, wenn wir das nicht haben, dann gibt es morgen mehrere Tote. Dieses Argument, sich da in ein emotionales Boxhorn treiben zu lassen, das ist, glaube ich, eines, dem die Politik leider sehr offen gegenübersteht. Und das ist natürlich ein Teil dieses großen globalen Debakels, das habe ich vor Weihnachten versucht zu beschreiben, das ist diese Teufelsspirale der Überwachung, die einfach bedeutet, wenn es keinen Anschlag gibt, dann weil die Überwachung da ist. Wenn es einen Anschlag gibt, dann weil nicht genug Überwachung da ist. Und wenn man den Anschlag aufklären kann, dann wegen der Überwachung. Das bedeutet, es gibt einfach nur die Möglichkeit, dass es mehr Überwachung gibt. Die Spirale lädt sich nur in eine Richtung. Und das ist natürlich etwas, was sich übrigens durch alle Parteien zieht. Und das ist auch etwas, was das Prinzip der einzige Punkt, wo schade ist, dass die FDP nicht mehr im Bundestag ist, weil man jetzt tatsächlich sieht, ernsthaft sieht, dass es mit Sabine Leuthasar-Schnarrenberger offenbar jemanden gab, der darauf zumindest in Ansätzen Wert gelegt hat und das andere darauf nicht ganz so viel Wert legen.
Naja, das ist offensichtlich. Ich meine, ich will jetzt auch nicht zu viel Verschwörung da aus der Tube quetschen.
Muss man ja gar nicht, die Realität reicht ja.
Aber es klingt halt schon sehr, dass es halt einfach auch diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung scheint mir auch so in gewissen Sicherheitskreisen und vielleicht eben auch in Geheimdienstkreisen einfach ein Dogma zu sein.
Das ist auf jeden Fall.
Das ist einfach eine Maßnahme, die hat einfach zu erfolgen und zwar allein, weil eine bestimmte Gruppe das gefordert hat. Und sie ist nicht bereit, dieses Machtinstrument aus der Hand zu geben, ob sie es nun brauchen oder nicht. Weil lustigerweise, das ist ja auch insofern ein bisschen albern, wir haben ja gemerkt, dass die Geheimdienste sich ohnehin über alles hinwegsetzen, was rechtlich, also es kann ja durchaus sein, dass viel von dem bereits längst stattfindet und es sozusagen eigentlich nur noch deshalb unbedingt beschlossen werden muss, damit man dann vielleicht in der Zukunft so eine Möglichkeit hat zu sagen, na wieso, aber fünf Jahre davon war es doch sogar legal.
Ich glaube, da kann man ganz wie in den allermeisten Fällen ganz ohne Verschwörungstheorie operieren. Da kann man einfach sehen, was ernsthaft gesagt, gefordert wird und was ernsthaft da ist. Es ist natürlich irgendwie so eine Art, ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen heiliger Gral, aber es ist so ein Punkt, der muss einfach kommen. Und lustigerweise ist es das glaube ich von beiden Seiten. Denn auch von meiner Seite aus, und ich bin ein bitterter Kämpfer gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und habe auch schon mir einiges anhören müssen, denn auch ich sehe natürlich, dass das eigentlich für mich eher ein Symbol des Überschreitens der roten Linie ist. Das ist nämlich der eigentliche Punkt.
Ach du hättest gerne das jetzt endlich mal beschließen, damit das Weinbild klar ist?
Nee, nein, nein, nein, dann hab ich das falsch ausgedrückt. Für mich ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in erster Linie schlimm, weil damit Überwachungsinstrumente legitimiert werden, die ohne Verdacht auskommen. Das ist für mich der Kern. Das ist für mich eine rote Linie. Und deswegen ist es für mich ja auch so, egal, ob das zwei Monate, sechs Monate, acht Monate, ob das nur linksrum oder auf dem Server oder auf jedem Server gespeichert. Das ist mir alles völlig schnurz. Warum? Es geht mir um diese rote Linie, die überschritten wird in dem Moment, wo verdachtlos überwacht wird. Jetzt kann man darüber spreiten, ob das schon Überwachung ist, wenn Daten gespeichert werden. Ich glaube, ja, aber da kann man, wie gesagt, darüber streiten.
Die NSA streitet darüber auch sehr gerne.
Wer?
Die NSA. Es gab einen schönen Vortrag.
Ich glaube, die streiten nicht so richtig darüber. Jedenfalls nicht intern.
Nee, die machen das ganz anders. Es gab einen schönen Vortrag auf den Kongress, der diese ganzen Programme mal vorgestellt hat. Und dann auch diese Problematik der Sprachregelung. Also zum Beispiel so auf Nachfrage, ob denn die Daten, ob sozusagen über eine Überwachung, eine Speicherung stattgefunden hat. Also ja, nein, technisch nennen wir es nicht Collecting, wenn wir nicht reinschauen.
Das sind alles ganz, man erkennt an der Sprache die Ziele dieser Leute. Und mit dieser Leute meine ich einer international agierenden, auch transnational agierenden Geheimdienst- und Sicherheitsmaschinerie. Man kann da ja auch ganz schwierig trennen im Übrigen zwischen Unternehmen und Staat. Das ist ja auch klar. Und man kann glaube ich auch nicht trennen, so wie es in der Presse häufig getan wird, zwischen NSA und befreundeten und angrenzenden Diensten. Da ist sehr viel, was sehr eng miteinander verbunden ist.
Wie siehst du denn, also Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja so das eine Thema, was diesen Mythos der netzpolitischen Bewegung irgendwann mal begründet hat, wo sich der größte Teil dessen, was man Netzgemeinde nennt, irgendwie drin geeint sieht. Und auch ein Thema, was uns seit Jahren beschäftigt. Also ich hatte irgendwann mal so einen vorsichtigen Hoffnungsschimmer, als ich das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts dazu...
Dann hat man näher reingeguckt und dann stand da bloß, ja, ihr dürft, aber nicht so.
Dieses Thema kommt immer wieder. Wie siehst du das? Also wie fühlt sich das für dich an? Welchen Blick willst du darauf? Gibt es überhaupt eine Möglichkeit, diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung einfach mal ein für alle Mal loszuwerden?
Nee, das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich bedanke mich für diese Frage.
Das ist nett, dass mir auch mal eine gute gelungen ist.
Es sind da schon mehrere gute. Es ist deswegen eine sehr gute Frage, weil sie auf ein Grundproblem hinweist. Übrigens auch ein Grundproblem, das mit meiner Ernüchterung, Enttäuschung, Naivität, Kränkung wie auch immer zu tun hatte. Nämlich, es ist nicht so, dass man irgendwann einen Stand erreicht hätte. Und den hat man dann erreicht und dann kann man weitermachen. Es ist ein andauernder Kampf. Und es gibt immer wieder Rückschläge. Es gibt substanzielle Rückschläge. Es gibt Niederschläge. Und es geht weiter. Und auch wenn irgendwo dann angenommen übermorgen wird die Netzneutralität ins Gesetz geschrieben, dann geht der Kampf für die Netzneutralität ärgerlicherweise trotzdem noch weiter. Es ist nicht so, dass man irgendwann ankommt und dann ist man da und dann sitzt man glücklich und dann kann man sich um die anderen Sachen kümmern. Das ist einfach nicht so. Und das hängt mit dem Aufbau der Welt zusammen. Das ist schon immer ein Ausloten von Interessen, ein Aneinanderpreilen, ein Verhandeln. Dann ist die eine mal größer und dann ist die andere mal größer und dann implodiert die eine und dann explodiert die andere und so weiter und so fort. Der Punkt dahinter ist auch mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Das wird nicht aufhören. Vielleicht ändern sich da die Namen, aber das Spiel an sich ändert sich nicht. Da sind die einen, die sagen Bürgerrechte, weniger Überwachung, und da sind die anderen mehr Überwachung, was habt ihr denn dauernd mit euren doofen Bürgerrechten. Und die haben unterschiedliche Spielfelder. Das Spielfeld jetzt seit 2005 hier oder 2005. Der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist, sagen wir mal so, immer wieder ein wiederkehrendes Hauptspielfeld. Der Spähe-Skandal ist jetzt ein ganz neues, völlig übergeordnetes Spielfeld. Und das wird weitergehen. Das ist, wenn wir es geschafft haben, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung irgendwie zu beerdigen, auf welche Art und Weise auch immer, dann kommt übermorgen jemand mit einem neuen Konzept um die Ecke. Und man braucht wieder einen Namen und die kämpfen wieder dafür. Und dann heißt das vielleicht irgendwie Nachratsdatenspeicherung oder keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls ist das auch ein Teil der Ernüchterung. Man kommt nie an, man muss immer weiter kämpfen. Das ist ein Prozess.
Den neuen Begriff gibt es schon. Er heißt Mindestspeicherfrist.
Nee, das ist ja das Gleiche nochmal mit einem anderen Namen. Ich rede davon, dass es sich wirklich weiterentwickelt. Ach so. Und das war ja auch irgendwie nur ein Stunt der zwischendurch von der CDU. Inzwischen benutzt den ja schon keiner mehr.
Ja, der war ein bisschen misslungen so.
Ich erkenne an, das ist ein schöner Versuch gewesen. Also man muss auch mal sagen, danke für diesen Versuch.
Kommen wir zu etwas, was das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik in dem letzten Monat ungefähr beschäftigt hat. Ihnen ist zugespielt worden die Kenntnis über 16 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen, die offensichtlich Deutschen gehören, denn sie enden ja auf DE.
Klar, das ist auch das Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Und sie kamen zusammen mit Passwörtern und scheinen dem BSI zugetragen worden zu sein von unabhängigen Forschern, die sich mit Botnetzen befassen und offensichtlich einen Command-and-Control-Server von einem solchen Botnetz aufgemacht haben und dort auf diese Liste von E-Mails und E-Mail-Adressen und Passwörtern gestoßen sind, die dem BSI zugänglich gemacht haben. Das BSI hat dann ungefähr einen Monat gebraucht, um eine Webseite aufzusetzen, sicherheitstest.bsi.de, wo man dann in einem komplizierten datenschutzfreundlich geprüften Verfahren seine E-Mail-Adresse eingeben kann. Die wird dann an den Server geschickt. Dort wird über die E-Mail-Adresse ein Hash generiert. Es wird in der Datenbank auf diesem Server nachgeschaut, ob sich darin eine E-Mail-Adresse befindet, zu der dieser Hash gehört. Sollte das der Fall sein, wird eine Informations-E-Mail an diese E-Mail-Adresse gesendet und es wird gesagt, du bist befallen. Jetzt könnte man sich fragen, warum die das nicht von vornherein einfach gemacht haben. Meine Theorie ist, dass sie nicht in der Lage waren, 16 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen in das CC-Feld von Outlook zu kopieren. Aber man hätte da ja auch eine andere technische Lösung finden können.
Das ist eine sehr ungerechte These. Ich habe dazu eine differenzierte Meinung.
Das ist schön, dass deine Meinung differenzierter ist.
Ich teile sie gerne mit euch. Zum einen glaube ich, dass solche Institutionen wie BSI wahnsinnig wichtig sind und auch wichtiger werden müssen. Zum anderen muss ich aber auch die Praxis betrachten, wie was getan wird. Da muss ich dem BSI ein Kompliment aussprechen. Die Art und Weise, wie sie das gemacht haben, ist auf so vielen Ebenen unklug. Das ist ein fantastisches, erschreckendes Beispiel. Der erste Punkt, den ich ganz deutlich kritisieren möchte, ist alleine aus Nutzerperspektive. Ich habe das nämlich gemacht. Ich habe deine Mail-Adresse eingetragen. Eine Mail-Adresse eingetragen, über die ich verfüge, so muss man es sagen.
Eine, die du unter Kontrolle hast.
Ja, weitestgehend. Ich bin die NSA. Und da habe ich das eingetragen und dann habe ich mir den Prozess mal genauer angeguckt, allein aus Nutzer-Sicht. Und das ist dann ernsthaft so, dass sie dann auf dieser Seite schreiben, ah, vielen Dank, dass wir prüfen, jetzt ob ihre Adresse mitverseucht ist. Und wenn das so ist, dann schicken wir ihnen eine PGP-signierte Mail, die im Betreff folgenden vierstelligen Zahlen- und Buchstabencode hat. Wenn sie keine Mail bekommen, dann ist ihre Mail-Adresse auch nicht verseucht.
Das war wirklich PGP-signiert.
Ich krieg's nicht mehr im Einzelfall zusammen, aber ich glaube, es war genauso.
PGP-signiert mit der Adresse No-Reply-at-PSI-DE.
Also, das ist auf so vielen Ebenen so ein Unklug, das zu tun. Und es ist schade, weil bei der BSI ja auch wirklich gute Leute eigentlich arbeiten. Und die Frage für mich, wie kann man es überhaupt machen, dass jemand das Gefühl hat, ah, meine Mail-Adresse ist sicher, und dass man das auslösen möchte durch eine Nicht-Aktion. Das heißt, nur diejenigen, die verseucht sind, kriegen überhaupt eine Mail. Und die anderen sollen sich sicher fühlen, weil sie keine Mail bekommen haben. Die werden in den nächsten Tagen, jeder Bürger, der das gemacht hat, wird dann überlegen, und wenn sie im Spam-Folder ist, vielleicht habe ich sie übersehen. Oder der Server war auch down, vielleicht ist die Mail gar nicht rausgegangen. Ich habe ja schon häufig Mails nicht bekommen. Das heißt, das Vorgehen von BSI schürt unfassbare Unsicherheit. Sogar bei den Leuten, die gar nicht betroffen sind. Und das ist alleine für mich schon auf einer sozialen Ebene der totale Vorpaar. Das ist auf technischer Ebene noch 30 andere Sachen, die man anders hätte machen können.
Wir wollen so fair sein und zumindest erklären, warum sie das so gemacht haben. Sie wollen damit verhindern, dass sie Adressen sammeln. Das ist der Grund, warum sie Adressen, die nicht in der Datenbank stehen, nicht kontaktieren. Und zweitens wollen sie verhindern, dass ich die Information über die Infektion einer anderen Person erlangen kann. Das heißt, ich kann nicht deine Adresse da eingeben und die Information erlangen, dass du dich unter dem Aufwand befindest.
Das Allermindest, was man machen könnte, ist doch eine Mail nicht zu schicken, sie sind nicht infiziert, sondern eine Mail zu schicken, sie sind nicht infiziert.
In dem Fall hätten sie aber Adressen sammeln können. Nee, hätten sie nicht.
Es gibt ganz moderne Technologien, wo man Daten sofort dann löscht, wenn man sie einmal benutzt hat. Insofern, das ist für mich einfach ein totales Wrong-by-Design quasi.
Ein wunderschönes Fehler, den sie auch da drin haben, ist, die Signatur über eine PGP-Nachricht schließt explizit den Betreff nicht mit ein. Das heißt, sie signieren quasi alles, außer diesen zentralen Code.
Der sicherstellen soll, dass es nicht missbraucht.
Das ist wunderbar.
Das ist jetzt auf einer sehr nerdigen Ebene.
Ich bin halt nerd.
Da muss ich mich entschuldigen.
Aber interessante Zahlen sind ja jetzt auch genannt worden. Wir haben also dort eine Datenbank mit 16 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen. Das heißt, 16 Millionen Menschen sind betroffen. Oder 16 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen sind betroffen. Dadurch, dass der Server irgendwie einige Zeit nicht geantwortet hat, weil er natürlich unter einer Massensturm von Menschen gelitten hat, sind immerhin 8,5 Millionen Abfragen bis heute Morgen irgendwann durchgeführt worden. Das heißt, 8,5 Millionen Adressen wurden geprüft. Von diesen 8,5 Millionen Adressen waren ungefähr 750.000 betroffen. Das heißt, von den Menschen, die dort den Test gemacht haben, sind gerade mal 9% betroffen.
Das ist nicht gerade mal, das ist ganz schön viel, würde ich sagen.
Ist interessant, relativiert an den 16 Millionen E-Mail-Adressen, die sich in dieser Datenbank befinden, ist das natürlich eine relativ geringe Trefferquote.
Zum einen glaube ich, dass diejenigen, die hier infiziert sind, eine viel kleinere Chance haben, überhaupt auf so eine Seite zu gehen und das zu prüfen. Ich meine, es ist jetzt auch kein totales Geheimnis, dass man in erster Linie dann so einen Datenverlust erleiden kann, wenn man jetzt nicht so super fit und firm in allen Internet-Dingen ist. Nicht allein, nur, das ist auch vollkommen klar, das kann jedem passieren, mir, euch, allen. Es ist bloß die Chance, dass es passiert ist, bei manchen Größen, bei manchen Größeren, bei manchen Kleiner. Und das wiederum veranlasst mich jetzt auch zu sagen, in Frage zu stellen, ob das das richtige Vorgehen überhaupt ist, eine Internetseite ins Netz zu stellen, wo ich mal unterstellen würde, dass es sehr viele Leute gibt, die eine Mail-Adresse mit.de haben, weil sie sich irgendwo eingerichtet haben, die dann kompromittiert worden ist und die überhaupt nicht so genau wissen, wie man auf eine Seite geht und was man da eingibt und was irgendwelche Scha, P, K, P, was das alles ist. Das ist für mich fraglich, ob man da den richtigen Weg eingeschlagen hat. Insofern würde ich diesen neuen Prozent sogar als relativ hoch bewerten.
Ja, also stellt sich die Frage, wie hätten wir es uns besser vorstellen können? Also sie hätten natürlich einfach die ganzen Anbieter schon mal kontaktieren können.
Also das allererste wäre, dass...
Viel mehr davon wird online oder sowas sein.
Also das absolute Basic würde ich jetzt mal mit Sherlock Holmes sagen wir erst mal zu überlegen, also deduktiv vorzugehen und erst mal versuchen, woher ist denn dieses Lieg? Das ist doch etwas, was man erst mal rausfinden muss. Also wo kommt... Also das wurde ja quasi ans BSI geleakt. Wo kommt das denn her und wo hat diese Person das her? Das bedeutet diese kompromittierten Mail-Adressen, wie sind die entstanden? Bei 16 Millionen kann man eigentlich ausschließen, dass irgendwie so ein drittklassiger Schuhshop gehackt wurde oder sowas. Insofern, bei 16 Millionen Adressen, die mutmaßlich alle auf die gleiche Art und Weise weggefischt worden sind, muss es eine Quelle geben.
Das scheint dieses Botnetz zu sein. Was ist denn nun das Problem?
Das wäre dann noch schlimmer als eine Einzelkette.
Du hast also ein viel größeres Problem.
Wenn du Teil eines Botnetzes bist, dann ist das sie. Was sie jetzt gemacht haben, ist ein Schrot-Schuss mit Augen zu, ins Überall. Selbst dieses Botnetz hat doch eine Aufgabe, eine Struktur. Man hätte doch sagen können, wenn sie mit ihrer Mail-Adresse einen Rechner vom Typ X benutzt haben, dann ist die Chance am höchsten. Irgendwie ein bisschen einzugrenzen, woher das kommt, wie das funktioniert, was das überhaupt für eine Botnetzübernahme von welchen Rechnern war. War das ein Botnetz, was sich auf Mail-Servern eingehackt hat, die nicht gesichert waren? Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß halt wahnsinnig wenig.
Also von dem, was ich da jetzt gelesen habe, eher unwahrscheinlich. Ich würde davon ausgehen, dass das die Client-Rechner sind, die da befallen sind. Und da wäre natürlich sowieso das erste, was ich als Botnet-Eigner machen würde, sofern die Annahme zutrifft, dass dieses Botnetz auch noch aktiv ist, ist, dass ich meinen kleinen Bots beibringe, dass sie zu sicherheitstest.bsi.de bitte schön keine Verbindungen mehr herstellen.
Ja, oder dass sie das geschmeidig umleiten auf eine solide russische Adresse.
Oder eben diese E-Mail-Adresse.
Ich meine, wenn die Rechner eh übernommen sind, dann ist ja sowieso hinfällig. Es ist völlig hinfällig.
Also schön, aber ein Massenleak an E-Mail-Adressen und Passwörtern, wie es noch nie da gewesen ist. Und von den 16 Millionen sind jetzt gerade mal ungefähr 7.000, 800.000 Personen bis jetzt informiert.
Genau. Was übrigens, ich möchte jetzt nicht zu sehr drauf umreiten, aber unser Eingangsthema vielleicht nochmal von der anderen Seite aus sich betrachten lässt. Natürlich kann man sich fragen, warum E-Mail eine so wahnsinnig unsichere Technologie ist in allen Ecken und Enden. Natürlich kann man sagen, wenn man so ein bisschen die alten Opas reden hört, dass das alles zufällig zustande gekommen ist. Man kann sich aber auch fragen, warum einfach wir mit E-Mail ein System haben, was eben so missbrauchsanfällig ist und warum die Bemühungen, das weniger missbrauchsanfällig zu machen, zum Beispiel wie die DE-Mail, alle entweder stockdumm oder substanziell auf der falschen Seite sind. Das ist eine für mich legitime Frage.
Ich habe mal versucht, die zu beantworten mit einem kleinen Vortrag beim Kongress.
Kannst du mal die Essenz davon? Weil es ist eine Frage, die mich ernsthaft interessiert.
Wir sind in der Sendung so weit fortgeschritten. Ich finde es jetzt einerseits blöd, die Frage nicht zu beantworten. Andererseits würde ich sagen, dass die Beantwortung so lange dauert. Eine der zentralen Thesen, die ich in dem Vortrag vertrete, ist natürlich zu sagen, so kein Staat geht hin und baut seinen Bürgern ein Kommunikationsmedium, was er am Ende nicht abhören kann. Das ist also die kurze Essenz dieses Vortrags. Ich habe noch mit ein paar anderen Sachen auseinandergesetzt, aber es ist ein einstündiger Vortrag, den würde ich jetzt gerne nochmal machen.
Nein, nein, das ist in Ordnung.
Ich liche dir ans Herz. Tim hat schon rote Augen. Wir kommen zu den Porno-Abmahnungen.
Ah, na dann geht es mir wieder besser.
Da geht es wieder um ein bisschen was Technisches. Und zwar bis mit dem Fall ungefähr vertraut. Diese RedTube-Abmahnungen.
Ungefähr vertraut. Ja, das ist mir schon alles ein Begriff. Das habe ich verfolgt.
Wir hatten das Thema jetzt hier in den letzten Sendungen schon mindestens einmal. Oder hatten wir es schon zweimal? So auch in der letzten Sendung. Was gibt es denn da jetzt Neues?
Genau, wir erinnern uns, es ging darum, dass das Kölner Landgericht gesagt hat, wir erkennen erstens das Verletzen des Urheberrechts an durch das Schauen eines Streams. Und zweitens akzeptieren wir die technische Methode der IP-Adressenfeststellung. Und geben deshalb diese Bescheide heraus, dass die Eigner dieser IP-Adressen festgestellt werden, sodass dann der Abmahnende denen eine Abmahnung zukommen lassen kann. Und Basis dieser Entscheidung war ein Gutachten über die technische Tauglichkeit der Software Gladi, so wie sie, glaube ich, hieß, von der bis heute keiner weiß, wie sie funktioniert. Deswegen wurde relativ heiß erwartet dieses Gutachten, angefertigt von der Patentsanwaltskanzlei Deal und Partner, wo jetzt erklärt wurde, wie die Patentsanwaltskanzlei dieses Verfahren geprüft haben. Sie haben folgendes getan. Sie haben drei nicht näher spezifizierte, geeignete Streams angeklickt, haben dann den Download stattfinden lassen. Und haben sich dann bei dem Web-Interface der GLADIS-Software eingeloggt. Und haben dort gesehen, dass ihr Zugriff auf dieses Streams ordnungsgemäß von dieser Software protokolliert wurde. Ende des Gutachtens.
Drei.
Das heißt, sie haben nur so einen Positivtest gemacht und sich überhaupt nicht den Code angeschaut. Oder sich nicht erklären lassen, wie das Ding eigentlich wirklich funktioniert.
Richtig.
Wo es installiert ist oder sonst was.
Also dahinter steht ein wahnsinns Problem, was Teil der Diskussion sein muss. Wie die digitale Gesellschaft aufgebaut ist. Und das ist, das ist ja alte Binsenweisheit von Larry Lessig. A Code is Law. Dass sich tatsächlich bestimmte Gesetze und Gesetzmäßigkeiten in der Technologie spiegeln müssen. Und es extrem wenig Leute gibt, die sowohl von Recht als auch von Programmiersprachen und deren Wirkung eine Ahnung haben. Das halte ich deswegen für ein großes Problem. Weil genau in solchen Fällen eigentlich jemand, der damit sachkundig vertraut ist, auf einen Blick sieht, dass das ein galaktischer Humbug sein könnte. Also so einfach von der Vorgehensweise, wie das angeblich zustande kommt. Und dass aber nicht nur so ein Patentanwalt, der eigentlich dafür zuständig sein müsste, das offenbar nicht erkennt oder nicht erkennen will, sondern dass auch alle Leute, die vor Gericht dann dieses Gutachten prüfen, ohne mit der Bimper zu zugen, ja es sieht plausibel aus, also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das richtig ist.
Ja, weil das wurde ja von Experten bestätigt.
Genau, genau. Das ist übrigens auch noch so ein Punkt des Experten. Also Deutschland ist ja das wahnsinnig expertenhörige Land überhaupt. Aber genau diesen Punkt möchte ich herausheben. Wir haben hier eine einzelne Blüte eines extrem wichtigen strukturellen Problems, dass die Welt, die digitale Gesellschaft geprägt wird durch Leute, die mit Programmiersprache umgehen können und dass auf der anderen Seite sie verwaltet und in Gesetze gegossen wird von Leuten, die es überhaupt nicht können. Und dass die Kommunikation zwischen diesen beiden Welten Übersetzer erfordert. Und davon gibt es wahnsinnig wenig. Es gibt wahnsinnig wenig Leute in diesem Bereich.
Du kritisierst jetzt hauptsächlich dieses Verfahren der Prüfung überhaupt. Du hast gerade schon laut gesagt drei. Also man hätte natürlich irgendwie mal vernünftig randomisieren müssen. Sie haben ja offensichtlich drei geeignete Adressen aufgerufen.
Ich kritisiere... Das ist eine Farce. Das ist noch nicht mal kritikwürdig. Das ist eine Farce.
Das Problem, was ich bei diesem ganzen Ding sehe, ist, da gibt es offensichtlich eine Website unterhalten von Dritten, wo ich mich einloggen kann und sehen kann, welche Kommunikation zwischen einem Server und dessen Client stattgefunden hat. Woher kommt diese Information? Also, haben Sie Wireshark in dem Rechenzentrum sitzen, wo der Porno-Server steht und gucken da die Verbindungen an? Haben Sie Werbung eingeblendet?
Es gab Gerüchte, dass sich über eine Art Virus angeblich verbreitet haben. Ich kann das alles überhaupt nicht einschätzen und kommentieren, weil ich weder in der Lage bin, die Daten, wenn sie dich denn hätte, zu analysieren, noch habe ich die Daten. Also ich kann es doppelt nicht sagen. Was ich aber weiß, dass es auch genau ein Problem ist, von dem ich hier gerade angesprochen habe, nämlich, dass sich feinste juristische Definitionen stützen auf technologische Vorgänge und man eigentlich beides überblicken und beherrschen muss, um ein vernünftiges Urteil fällen zu können. Und das ist hier nicht der Fall.
In der Realität sieht es also so aus, dass der Anwalt hier schreibt in seinem Gutachten, die Maßnahmen der Erfassung beruhen technisch auf üblichen Internettechnologien, welche beim Einsatz in dem verwendeten Testszenario keine Bedenken hinsichtlich etwaiger Gesetzesverstöße erkennen lässt.
Das war alles, was er dazu sagte.
Das schreibt der Anwalt in seinem Gutachten. Also ich hätte jetzt eigentlich mal gedacht, dass das eine Entscheidung ist, die der Richter zu verhelfen hat, ob jetzt diese Methode...
Aber da siehst du ja schon, dass man damit so ein bisschen Staubgewerfe und Fachbegriffs... Also das ist ja noch nicht mal gut. Es ist ja sogar noch schlecht gefakt. Ja, also übliche Internettechnologien. Wir testen das mit völlig unüblichen Internettechnologien. Also da sieht man die Dimension des Problems. Also es ist ja eine Sache, eine Expertise zu haben, die dir erlaubt, nachzuvollziehen, ob das wirklich so ist, wie das steht. Eine zweite Sache ist, einschätzen zu können. Das hätte ich jetzt auch nicht, wenn es so ein ernsthaftes technisches Gutachten ist. Eine zweite Sache ist, zu sehen, ob da jemand gefaked hat. Und zwar entweder gut gefaked, das ist häufig schwierig zu erkennen, aber wenn man jemand so schlecht und so dümmlich faked, wenn man das dann noch nicht mal mehr erkennt, das ist dann besorgniserregend. Und das zeigt auch, dass wir in ganz vielen Bereichen, das strahlt ab auf fast alle anderen Diskussionen, in ganz vielen Bereichen haben wir nicht unbedingt falsche Gesetze, sondern welche, wenn man das ernst meint, nicht wirklich angewendet oder nicht in ihrer Anwendung so benutzt werden könnte, wie es eigentlich sein müsste. Da gibt es so wahnsinnig viele Beispiele für, dass einfach die Art und Weise, wie mit den Gesetzen umgegangen wird, einfach deutlich macht, dass auch ein schärferes Gesetz nichts ändern würde.
Lass uns doch mal bitte von der globalen Betrachtung nochmal auf den konkreten Fall zurückkommen. Gibt es denn außer dieser Gutachtendarlegung noch weitere Erkenntnisse? Weil der Verdacht, dass das Ganze über mehr oder weniger illegal betriebene Proxys umgeleitet wurde, also dass diese Nutzer sozusagen auf ganz anderes Hals umgelenkt wurden, der war ja letzte Woche schon relativ offensichtlich.
An dem ändert das Gutachten nichts.
Aber was natürlich noch anders spannend ist...
Moment, das ist aber alles jetzt sozusagen.
Das war jetzt alles zu diesem Gutachten. Ich habe ja immer noch die technische Perspektive dazu. Meine Empörung gilt natürlich dieser Art, wie dieses Gutachten da angefertigt wurde.
Meine Empörung gilt eher, dass es einfach durchgegangen ist. Weil, dass es böse Menschen gibt, die komische Gutachten anfertigen, das ist mir quasi gegeben. Für mich ist es eher schwierig, dass ein Richter oder jedenfalls jemand vom Gericht, der das geprüft hat, sich das anschaut oder eben noch nicht mal mehr anschaut und durchwinkt. Das ist für mich die Säubbruchstelle.
Was glaubst du oder rechnest du damit, dass das jetzt aufgerollt wird? Also das Landgericht Köln hatte sich ja schon von seiner ursprünglichen Entscheidung da distanziert.
Kann ich schwierig sagen. Also da sind, gerade wenn man im juristischen Apparat Vermutungen anstellt, dann hat man eine sehr hohe Enttäuschungsquote, weil da die Gesetze eben im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes ganz anders funktionieren, als man am Anfang glaubt oder sich noch völlig seltsame Nebenkriegsschauplätze ergeben und so. Da möchte ich überhaupt keine Prognose treffen. Was ich aber glaube, ist, dass dieser Fall auch sein Gutes hat, nämlich dass in Zukunft vermutlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit in genau solche Vorgänge gesteckt wird, weil das ist natürlich schon maximal peinlich für das Gericht in Köln. Also das ist schon sehr unangenehm, dass sie sich da so haben verarschen lassen. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass in Zukunft irgendwelche beliebigen Gutachten oder IP-Adressen, Herausgabeveruche, eine Spur ernsthafter betrachtet werden. Viel wichtiger ist diese Diskussion übrigens auch in dem Bereich, der tatsächlich in manchen juristischen Rechtsprechungsarten eine Unklarheit darstellt, nämlich ob Streaming jetzt einen Kopiervorgang darstellt. Das ist ja so quasi ganz im Hintergrund. Das ist eine Metafrage, die sie sagt. Das ist eine Metafrage und übrigens gar keine ganz unwichtige Metafrage. Ich kann mich an eine Zeit erinnern, ich mache ja nicht mehr illegale Sharing-Sachen, das mache ich nicht mehr, schon eine ganze Weile, weil ich mich dazu entschlossen habe, das nicht zu tun, auch wenn es manchmal sehr, sehr schwer fällt, weil natürlich die Content-Industrie da einfach totalen Hau hat in ganz vielen Bereichen. Aber als ich das mal gemacht habe in der Zeit, war einer von den ganz naheliegenden und billigen Tricks eben, dass du bei Safari einfach in der Aktivität gucken konntest, welche Files beim Streaming geladen werden und die einzelnen Files adressieren und runterladen konntest. Also als eine Standardfunktion bei Safari damals zumindest gewesen, will sagen, ich hab mir irgendwo angeguckt, wo irgendein Stream oder irgendwas auf dem Server lag, was man eigentlich theoretisch hätte nicht vermeintlich runterladen können. Und dann war es halt mit einem Klick da doch irgendwie rausgesogen und downgeloadet auf so eine komische Art. Was es aber zeigt, ist, dass die Grenze zwischen Stream und Download nicht so einfach zu ziehen ist, auf technischer Ebene, wie man das vielleicht gerne hätte. Und zwar weder von der einen noch von der anderen Seite. Es ist ja überhaupt nicht so, dass ich sage, alle illegale Schweine einsperren.
Das ist juristisch leider erst mal unerheblich, weil die Abmahnungen ja Erfolgen für das Anbieten. Also du bekommst...
Du redest im Moment, also jetzt bei RedTube ja nicht.
Genau, das ist genau der andere Punkt. Das heißt nicht nur die Unterscheidung ist es ein Stream, ist es ein Download, sondern auch noch die Unterscheidung ist das Konsumieren dieses Streams, selbst wenn es ein Download ist, eine strafbewehrte Handlung. Die stellt sich dann trotzdem auch nochmal. Also selbst sei der Stream ein Download, selbst dann stellt sich die Frage, ob du die Strafe machst, wenn du diesen tätigst.
Das ist alles leider richtig und natürlich noch viel komplizierter. Das ist ja ein riesiger Graubereich, der noch unterteilt ist in verschiedene Subgraubereiche. Aber für mich ist eben spannend, wie da die Rechtsstellung sich vor ein Dilemma gestellt sieht, dass eben alte Bewertungsmuster nicht mehr funktionieren. Weil natürlich kann man sich vorstellen, dass Streaming im Moment irgendwie so eine lokale Kopie anfertigt, und das irgendwie so hin und her kascht oder so, das kennt ja jeder. Aber natürlich lässt sich genauso gut eine Technologie vorstellen, die tatsächlich immer nur einen bestimmten Datensatz hat und den davor und danach sofort wieder vernichtet, was insbesondere dann wichtig wird, wenn man anfängt, richtig massiv große 4K-Filme zu streamen. Du kannst ja gar nicht so große Festplatten irgendwie mehr in dein kleines Apple TV einbauen, wenn du so einen 4K-Stream irgendwie 70 Gigabyte einfach mal quer durchziehst. Du musst ja nur Bruchstücke daraus anfangen zu sehen. Insofern ist das nicht nur eine Graubereich, sondern auch noch eine Übergangsdiskussion.
Das ist sicherlich auch richtig. Wir werden sehen, wie sie endet und wenden uns dem letzten kurzen Thema zu. Vielleicht schaffen wir das nur als Meldung. Unsere Freunde von der Open Knowledge Foundation und der Website Frag den Staat haben eine Abmahnung bekommen. Und zwar haben sie mit Hilfe des Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes sich Zugang zu einer Stellungnahme des Bundesinnenministeriums verschafft. Haben diese auch gemäß dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz übersandt bekommen, mit dem Vermerk, dass sie sie aber bitte nicht veröffentlichen sollten.
Nach Informationsfreiheitsgesetz.
Genau.
Genau. Das ist ja nur auf Personen bezogen und nicht auf die Öffentlichkeit in vielen Fällen.
Es ging um die Bewertung eines Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteils zu Sperrklauseln bei Europawahlen, also Prozenthürden. Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist das Bundesverfassungsgericht zu der Einsicht gekommen oder hat die Position vertreten, dass solche Sperrklauseln nicht zulässig sind. Die Bundesregierung hat sich aber dazu entschieden, dennoch eine 3%-Sperrklausel, glaube ich, bei der Europawahl geltend zu machen. Und jetzt wurde also genau diese bewertung, die interne bewertung des Bundesinnenministeriums, dieses Urteils des Bundesverfassungsgerichtes übersandt. Und mit dem Argument, es handele sich nicht um ein amtliches Werk im Sinne des Urheberrechts und sei daher nicht gleichzusetzen mit einer Äußerung der Regierung gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit. Insofern habe die Regierung, in dem Fall das Bundesinnenministerium, ein Urheberrecht an diesem Text, gegen das jetzt von der Webseite fragt den Staat verstoßen wurde. Wir erinnern uns, gleich wurde argumentiert gegenüber netzpolitik.org, als es um die Geburtstagseinladungsliste von Josef Ackermanns Party im Schloss Bellevue im Kanzleramt ging. Da bekam netzpolitik.org dann auch die Abmahnung, oder die Bitte um Löschung, glaube ich. Eine Abmahnung war es nicht und hat ja erstmal nicht Folge geleistet. Dem ist dann auch danach geschah dann auch nichts weiter.
Das ist aber ein schönes Beispiel dafür, das sagt natürlich überhaupt nicht über das Urheberrecht, außer dass hier ein urheberrechtlicher Mechanismus benutzt wird, um eine missliebige Information zu unterdrücken. Wäre das nicht das Urheberrecht, würde man das irgendwie anders versuchen. Und wenn man die wegen der Brandschutzverordnung dran kriegt, würde man auch das versuchen. Es geht hier einfach darum...
Hier wird nach kreativen Lösungen gesucht, hier die Fresse zu halten. Und die Kreativen sollen ja auch unterstützt werden durch das Urheberrecht.
Das ist doch das erklärte Ziel. Das ist eine sehr schöne Formulierung, die du hier so als Stunt versuchst. Ich glaube, das Problem ist ein bisschen tiefer und eben nicht urheberrechtlich. Das ist hier ein Instrument, was einem zufällig im Weg rum lag. Das Problem ist, dass substanzielle Teile der Administration die Transparenz als Bedrohung ihrer Macht ansehen. Und das ist, glaube ich, eines der zentralen Probleme, wo wir einer digitalen Gesellschaft dem gegenüber stehen, dass wir rausfinden müssen, wie können wir auf der einen Seite mehr Transparenz in solche administrativen Prozesse reinbringen, ohne auf der anderen Seite, sagen wir mal, massiv ungerecht oder massiv arbeitseinschränkend zu wirken. Denn überall, alles, immer grundsätzlich nur Transparenz, das ist, glaube ich, eine utopische Forderung, die so nicht funktionieren kann.
Das sei dahingestellt. Jetzt ist ja auch in Ordnung. Jetzt ist natürlich das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz dafür, dass zumindest da punktuell, wo dann Interesse besteht, solche Informationen auch erlangt werden können.
Da ist das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz einfach broken. Beziehungsweise die Ausprägung, wie es gemacht wird. Wenn also ernsthaft man eine Auskunftsmöglichkeit hat und die bezieht sich, wie ich das jetzt zweimal bei Anfragen, die ich selber mitgemacht habe, über Frag den Staat, erlebt habe, die bezieht sich explizit nur auf die einzelne Person und nicht auf die Veröffentlichung, dann ist das natürlich nicht nur im Zeitalter von Internet, das kommt noch dazu, sondern dann ist das eigentlich eine substanzielle Schwächung und Vermöglichung von dem, was Transparenz eigentlich bringen soll.
Sie betteln ja geradezu darum, dass jetzt irgendwie alle, die diese Geschichte lesen, diesen Antrag nach IFG stellen, um auch die...
Ja, aber das wird dann halt viel weniger als Leute Artikel lesen. Und das ist natürlich eine Einschränkung von Informationen. Und Sie rechnen natürlich auch nicht, dass jemand, ich habe da mal von so einer Seite paste bin oder so gehört, rechnen Sie auch nicht damit, dass... Ja, das kannst du heutzutage mit einem Link ermöglicht werden können. Oder selbst wenn sie mitrechnen, dann ahnen sie, dass trotzdem weniger Leute diese Information dann sehen.
In dem Fall ist es ganz interessant, wenn man sich anschaut, in dieser Abmahnung wird dann natürlich auch der finanzielle Teil geklärt, wo sie sagen, der Gegenstandswert ist jetzt hier beziffert auf 10.000 Euro. Der Klage oder der Gegenstandswerk des Werkes, dessen Urheberrecht verlässt wurde. Und danach richtet sich ja dann bei einer Abmahnung die Geschäftsgebühr des abmahndenden Anwaltes. Die wird in Rechnung gestellt, die wird dann nach Rechtsanwaltsverordnungsgesetz oder so berechnet. Also da kann der Anwalt nicht einfach einen beliebigen Betrag verlangen, sondern das ist nach Verordnung geregelt. Richtet sich aber genau auf diese 10.000. Und das wird jetzt in Rechnung gestellt, 725,40 Euro Geschäftsgebühr, eine Auslagenpauschale von 20 Euro. Das ergibt also 745,40 Euro, auf die natürlich noch umsatzsteuerfällig werden, womit wir bei 887,03 Euro sind, die die Open Knowledge Foundation doch bitte bis zum 28. Januar zu zahlen hätte. Finde ich interessant, weil hier überhaupt gar keine Kompensation für einen Schaden verlangt wird. Das heißt, dieses Geld geht 745 brutto an den Anwalt und 141,63 Euro Umsatzsteuer an den Staat, der ja an der Stelle gefragt wurde. Üblicherweise wird dann natürlich auch noch, denke ich, eigentlich eine Kompensation fällig, dass man sagt, okay, die klagende Partei...
Du hättest es ja eigentlich legal lizenzieren können, hast du aber nicht gemacht.
Genau, das ist dann...
Hättest du ja auch nicht machen können.
Naja, freilich, also man könnte sich ja mal eine preiswisse schicken lassen, oder?
Fällig arbitäre Festlegungen dieses Wertes. Es fällt mir nebenbei noch ein. Aber bei Ueber ist das eigentlich...
Ja, aber das ist halt immer so. Das ist... Also der Kernpunkt für mich ist da, dass... Ich glaube, dass solche Dokumente eigentlich grundsätzlich niemals unter urheberrechtlichen Vorbehalt stehlen sollten. Das ist ja bei Teilen von den Staatsdokumenten auch so. Noch nicht mal bei allen bizarrerweise, aber bei Teilen ist das dann tatsächlich so. Aber dass jetzt ein Ministerium einfach so per Selbsterklärung sagt, ne, wir fallen da nicht runter, das ist jetzt doch urheberrechtlich, das ist natürlich eine Farce. Und da ist dann doch auch der Gesetzgeber gefragt, damit da irgendwelche mittleren Beamten, die das entschieden haben, werden nicht so durchdrehen und einfach irgendwas, irgendwie machen, sondern dass völlig klar ist, dass wenn sowas veröffentlicht wird, dass da eben nicht ein Urheberrecht drauf ist. Also das ist das Ministerium, das arbeitet ja für uns, was soll der Kram? Aber könnte man ja an so vielen Fragen, an so vielen Punkten diese Frage stellen.
Wir könnten uns noch an vielen Punkten noch viele Fragen stellen. An dieser Stelle denke ich, bleibt uns dir zu danken, dass du auf so viele Fragen deine Antworten gegeben hast.
Ja, genau Sascha, vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Jetzt müssen wir aber hier mal zum Ende kommen. Wir haben, glaube ich, sogar die Sendungslänge der Litzen-Sendung und der wir meinten, das wäre die Ausnahme. War wieder geflissentlich überschritten. Naja, so ist es halt hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Ich bedanke mich für eure Aufmerksamkeit und für freundlichen Fragen und hilfreichen Anmerkungen.
Und sagen Tschüss.